burning neighborhoods strings of
horrific Axe Murders a burger joint
selling human flesh and only one
question you mad bro fans of internet
memes from the mid 2000s might remember
one inescapable image commonly known as
Trollface Trollface and his trademark
grin symbolized mischief and
troublemaking and generally making the
world a more chaotic place over time as
is often the case on the internet new
variations on the image began to spring
up as users created their own spin on
Trollface at first it was all relatively
harmless but then again this is the
internet nothing online stays harmless
forever over time more Sinister
variations on Trollface began to surface
memes consisting of joke instructions
that took a dark destructive turn this
new spin on the Trollface quickly became
known as Trolla and often featured
disturbing content presented in a joking
prankster format still not something to
be too concerned about just standard
edgy posting trying to get a reaction by
shocking people right not exactly on
December 24th 2020 in Melbourne
Australia a college student named Lee
Miller received an early Christmas
present from her classmate and
ex-boyfriend Peter witkins the two had
parted on relatively good terms and she
was glad to receive a gift from him when
she opened it she was delighted to see
that he had purchased her a jar of
expensive French facial moisturizer one
she had been interested in trying back
when they were together as she prepared
to do her skincare routine that night
she thought about how thoughtful the
gift was and how sweet Peter was maybe
she'd made a mistake breaking things off
maybe after the holidays she could reach
out and see if they could give things
another shot as she unscrewed the jar of
moisturizer she didn't notice that its
color and smell seemed just a bit a off
she just dipped her fingers inside and
began to apply the cream to her face all
of a sudden she realized what a horrible
mistake that was her face began to burn
her skin screaming out in a pain like
none she'd ever felt before she screamed
clawing at her face desperate for a way
to make it stop neighbors heard the
screams and called Emergency Services
when paramedics arrived on the scene her
condition had gotten even worse they
restrained her sedated her and took her
to the hospital for treatment the face
cream was brought in for testing and was
found to have been tampered with it had
been spiked with gimpy gimpy one of the
world's most excruciatingly painful
plants Peter was promptly brought in for
questioning but refused to explain why
he had done it he was charged with
assault and officers inspected his home
for anything that might suggest a motive
on his computer they found the most
recent post he had read before
presumably committing the crime it was a
troll Jim formatted as a comic and it
read want to get back at your girlfriend
step one find out her favorite facial
cream step two procure the facial cream
step three obtain urien plant use gloves
step four blend the leaves with the
cream then repack it step five give
girlfriend the gift the meme contained a
six step but it was redacted in all
official records for reasons that will
soon become clear this incident caught
the attention of the SCP Foundation who
swiftly looked into the meme as a
potential anomaly as they were
conducting their investigation it
happened again another troia meme
another horrible crime with an
inexplicable motive on December 28th
2020 in bond AKA Indonesia 15 terminally
ill patients were found dead in their
hospital beds that wouldn't necessarily
be caused for alarm given the nature of
their conditions except for the cause of
death the patients did not pass away due
to their illnesses instead each and
every one of them was killed by carbon
monoxide poisoning at first the case was
a mystery until security footage
revealed that one of the hospital's
orderly Aziz hiat replaced the patient's
oxygen tanks with tanks of carbon
monoxide he was promptly arrested and
brought in for questioning during the
interrogation he repeated again and
again that he was not trying to harm the
patients but he was delivering them the
police officers asked who he was trying
to deliver them to but he refused to
answer a search through his computer
browser history uncovered another troll
J meme this one read want to help people
step one get a job at a hospital step
two make friends with the patients step
three enter oxygen tank room step four
replace tanks with carbon monoxide step
five release them from their defective
vessels the SCP Foundation had been in
the process of formulating a hypothesis
but now it was confirmed these
variations on the troll shamim contained
a cognito hazardous switch that would
cause a reader to carry out the acts
described in the comic the switch
appeared to specifically be contained in
the conclusive line hence its removal
from all official records of any
identified anomalous memes an estimated
25% of those exposed to an anomalous
meme would be affected by this Cognito
Hazard the phenomenon was given the
designation as SCP
6661 and the memes themselves SCP 6661
D1 these first two incidents were
nicknamed the pretty girl incident and
the sleepy time incident respectively
several other notable incidents occurred
following the discovery of SCP
6661 on January 20th 2021 the Harvester
Valley incident occurred Oliver desens
of Alberta Canada packed his bags full
of camping supplies fresh drinking water
a flashlight and an axe he kissed his
wife and children goodbye and he drove
out to the local tourist Campground
after Darkness fell he left his tent Axe
in Hand and walked from Camp to Camp
slaughtering anyone he came across he
managed to kill 10 people and injured 14
before he was killed by the authorities
everyone who knew Oliver was shocked
saying he had no history of violent
Behavior he wouldn't even kill a spider
when he found one inside his wife gave
the authorities permission to examine
his internet activity and sure enough
they found a troia meme left open want
to have a good holiday step one pack
necessary equipment and items step two
say goodbye to family step three drive
to the valley campgrounds step four find
local Shepherd and his flock step five
steal a little lamb step six relish upon
its flesh for it will be your dying meal
step seven data expunged after reading
the meme the foundation determined that
a nearby farmer was indeed missing one
of his sheep the bones of the missing
sheep were later discovered near the
campground where the attack took place
this new findings suggested that the
Cognito hazardous effects tended to
result in a largely ill literal
interpretation of the given memes text
Oliver himself could not be questioned
about his actions due to his death on
the scene so there were no more answers
to be uncovered in his case on February
16th 2021 in Bratislava Slovakia a man
named Joseph prasa began displaying
unusual behavior at around 0200 hours he
drove through his neighborhood in his
water truck and began using it to spray
kerosene upon nearby buildings
throughout the area the sound and the
smell woke several neighbors who
attempted to reason with Joseph and make
him stop what he was doing he ignored
them as if in a trance and carried on
with his task frightened for their
safety as well as that of their clearly
unwell neighbor they called emergency
services to the scene Emergency Services
arrived to find Joseph standing in front
of the active nozzle kerosene blasting
directly onto him he didn't even seem to
notice
as the authorities approached him
calling out to him asking him to come
with them he acknowledged their presence
he smiled broadly and pulled something
from his pocket all too late they
realized what it was a road flare he
ignited it and the area was swiftly
engulfed in flames 26 people were killed
in the blast and hundreds of thousands
in property damage occurred as a result
that was shocking enough but additional
emergency responders who arrived at the
scene saw something even more bizarre
began to rain putting out some of the
Flames as the water touched the kerosene
soaked bodies and Landscape paramedics
were completely taken aback as they saw
corpses and bits of rubble begin to
float up into the air up into the sky
one man later described what he had seen
to the police saying it was as if they
were floating on the water that was
falling from the sky the authorities
dismissed this account but the SCP
Foundation knew better this had to be
another troia incident indeed it was and
on Joseph's computer they found the
guilty meme oil is lighter than water
step one cover yourself in oil step two
feels good step three cover others in
oil step four data expunged somehow this
particular instance of SCP 6661 had
managed to alter the laws of physics to
bend them to its will it was a troubling
development and not something they cared
to see repeated containment procedures
were swiftly put into place web crawlers
monitored the internet for any
appearances of troia particularly those
that seem to have Cognito hazardous
properties if they could track these
instances and delete them from
circulation perhaps they could prevent
any more needless destruction during the
monitoring process some of the web
crawlers detected an instance of SCP
66611 with a heavily distorted
concluding step before expunging this
step Junior researcher Mel Ramirez
edited out the Distortion and scanned
the image image through a spectrogram
generator this was it should be noted
without prior authorization the
spectrogram generated audio three
recognizable
words Junior researcher Ramirez was
reprimanded for breaching protocol but
his work proved to be valuable enough to
Warrant additional research with the
sign off of the 05 Council a spectrogram
was constructed with a reply to this
question and spread through the internet
the foundation's response was yes yes we
see you who are you and why are you
doing this within 24 hours of the
foundation's response another SCP 66611
instance with a similar Distortion was
found the Distortion was isolated and
scanned through a spectrogram generator
once more it
[Music]
stated people forget
two
I am that I be weer people now like
darkness and
exposion embra Shadow chaos CH I exist
people see me I
life this Revelation gave the foundation
a new theory on the nature of SCP 666
one the initial Trollface meme was so
popular so widespread and beloved that
the collective energy directed towards
it created a thought form able to
manifest via the meme when Trollface
declined in popularity over the years
the thought form became desperate to
achieve the same relevance again it
gravitated towards darker subject matter
toward the shocking and disturbing in
order to get attention this resulted in
the creation of SCP
66611 an opportunity for the thought
form to feel seen again when it does not
feel seen when it is not fed energy and
attention the thought form becomes weak
and desperate the Cognito hazardous
effects may not be deliberate at all but
rather an unfortunate side effect of
this particular manifestation an
additional theory was proposed the way
to limit the effects of SCP
66611 to perhaps even eradicate it is to
make the original troll face popular
again the troll must be fed at first the
foundation was reluctant to put this
Theory into practice it seemed patent
absurd to many of the high-ups but the
percentage of susceptible individuals
began to increase and more and more
incidents occurred in July of 2021
residents of a small Virginia Town began
to go missing one by one until over a
dozen people had mysteriously
disappeared there appeared to be no
common link between the missing persons
until one unlikely thread surfaced tying
them all together shortly before their
disappearance each person had eaten a
meal at Billy's Burgers the local burger
joint police interrogated all employees
but no new information turned up they
checked security camera footage but only
one of the cameras at the small local
business was operational and it only
captured the restaurant's main entrance
it was beginning to look like one more
Dead lead that is until one of the
investigating officers heard his stomach
Rumble and decided to grab a burger and
fries for the road back at the police
station the officer sat down to enjoy
his lunch taking a big juicy bite out of
his Burger suddenly he felt something
hard crack against his tooth he reached
into his mouth and fished it out at
first he didn't believe his eyes but
sure enough there was a human finger
bone he hopped back in his police car
drove back to Billy's burgers and
demanded to investigate the kitchen
there wasn't anything out of the
ordinary right away but he trusted his
gut and the bite of the burger that he
had almost put it in he confiscated the
freshly ground meat and had it analyzed
the results came back and his stomach
dropped it was human once more the
police officer drove back to the Burger
Joint this time his lights were flashing
his siren was blaring and he was ready
to make an arrest when he arrived the
place was eerily quiet all the lights
were off he drew his weapon and crept
toward the back where he found the fry
cook Jeffrey tombs operating the meat
grinder next to the machine he could
make out bloody scraps of employee
uniforms and suddenly realized why the
place was so quiet Jeffrey was making
his co-workers into Burgers he arrested
Jeffrey and brought the young man into
custody all he would say over and over
again was I'm I made them better the SCP
Foundation caught wind of this
horrifying case and arrived to conduct
their own investigation they found
another Cognito hazardous meme this one
read everyone loves Burgers step one get
job at a burger place step two improve
on the recipe step three Source your own
meat step four profit step five expunged
the foundation attempted to interrogate
Jeffrey as well but he was still not
forthcoming he did say one thing however
he requested that for his dying meal in
prison he be given a burger after this
incident the order was given the
Trollface experiment would be carried
out a team of researchers sociologists
and statisticians was assembled and
asked to design images and media
involving troll face now designated SC
SCP
66612 the images were then disseminated
across the foundation internet
attempting to saturate the media with
this mimetic agent until it achieved a
status colloquially known as dank this
team was designated task force hexine
meme machine the initial experiment was
a success and the incidents began to
slightly reduce the all clear was given
and as SCP 6612 was disseminated across
the internet again incident numbers
decreased this allowed for standard
containment procedures to be put in
place procedures still in use today the
foundation has established a think tank
to observe the trends and popularity of
SCP
66612 if its popularity declines the
think tank will evaluate the best course
of action to take SCP 6612 based mimic
agents are to be spread across various
social media sites and the internet at
large as well as the foundation internet
Foundation webcrawlers must consistently
scan the internet at large for instances
of SCP
66611 and look for active SCP 66611
events if any instances are found the
concluding instructions must be redacted
whenever possible any Personnel that is
going to deal directly with SCP 66611
must be mimetically inoculated before
being assigned to the anomaly oh wait it
seems as though there's one more
mimetically infected comic let's see
here want to see the best videos on
YouTube step one log on step two find
SCP explained step three subscribe step
four ring the bell step five
redacted God damn it the comment section
on this one is going to be hell do your
worst you filthy
animals now before we begin today's
video let's clear some things up we know
exactly what you're thinking and among
us as CP this sounds ridiculous why
would the foundation ever have to deal
with an anomaly Rel relating to Among Us
of all things is this some kind of sick
joke dreamt up by our YouTube commenters
and look we get it it's definitely one
of the more ridiculous anomalies the
foundation has had to contain at least
at face value but there are a few things
you should take into consideration
before things get too a mugus pilled
around here oh God first this is hardly
the strangest anomaly we've covered on
SCP explained SCP 5981 also known as new
nuke City revolved around a mysterious
broadcast of a Family Guy episode SCP
4335 a wel in The Crucible had to deal
with an entity occupying space inside
the video game Minecraft but there are
countless other examples of anomalies
creeping into popular culture mutating
it and twisting it for their own
purposes what may seem silly on paper
such as the foundation having to do
research on a popular video game like
Among Us is all part of what the
organization does if the brave
researchers at the SCP Foundation
chuckled and brushed off a Potential
Threat just because it had to do with
something like Among Us the entire
population might be susceptible to a
supernatural event of unprecedented
proportions the foundation's entire veil
of secrecy could crumble all because
someone Shrugged off the possibility of
allocating resources to deal with a
threat millions of civilians could
discover these games movies and shows
are all immensely popular and in a ly
affecting a global phenomenon like among
us could spell Doom for not only the
foundation but the entire world as well
if left unchecked so if you don't want
to risk termination please try to keep a
straight face as we divulge into the
weird and wacky story of SCP
5167 an anomaly camed in the
foundation's database
as when the impostor is sus oh God I
hate ha my job sometimes to begin we
need to go back way way back centuries
before Among Us was even conceived as a
concept before video games had been
invented and even before electricity
itself was discovered back to an Era
where the gods of Olympus ruled Supreme
and stone marble statues line buildings
that would serve as Timeless Feats of
architecture and where a new school of
thought was developing one that focused
on logic and reason instead of
superstition and heay that's right we're
talking about ancient Greece a society
that for all of its achievements and
progression in the fields of Education
cultures and logic was still largely
governed by religion and mythology but
of course as you may come to Expect When
dealing with the SCP Foundation there's
always a little truth in that which we
cannot understand while those who are
unaware of the Paranormal might deride
the Greeks for being overly focused on a
Pantheon of gods they logically should
have no reason to believe those who know
that anything can happen in the world of
the anomalous may approach this topic
and the subject of religion in general
In a Different Light the Greek gods were
very real well the myths may not be
entirely true and they may not have been
literal Gods there were a group of
anomalous entities who influenced Greek
society performing miraculous Feats that
left those who observe them in complete
wonder and putting together cult of
worship surrounding them while most of
this was done in secret word of these
beings traveled incredibly fast in the
ancient world and they were heralded as
Gods beings of divine might that could
do anything in the universe who existed
above the Mortal plane and demanded
worship from their followers a glance at
Greek mythology paints a picture of a
group of gods who acted more less like
humans they fought they killed they
argued and they felt human emotions it's
likely that this characterization in the
stories emerged from how these entities
conducted themselves in actuality there
were dozens upon dozens of entities the
Greeks worshiped as Divinity and while
the stories portrayed the gods as
jealous vengeful beings who constantly
fought with each other it doesn't
compare to the reality of the situation
which was much more Cutthroat you see
there were 12 gods of Olympus and you
probably know most of them they're
remembered today for a reason Zeus
Athena Poseidon Aries the list goes on
we still remember these beings because
of the iconic stories they took part in
and how significant they were in ancient
times while for every Zeus god of
lightning there were five more Gods who
absolutely no one but the most hardcore
historical fanatic remember gods of
Niche subjects who had small followings
who never had those character defining
myths to flesh them out and preserve
them for all of history to remember who
would when gree fell Fade Into Obscurity
for every Zeus there was a python who
was python you ask well if the guy heard
you asking that question he'd probably
Smite you down before the question even
left your lips if he wasn't engaged in a
hardcore game of Among Us that is don't
worry we'll get there all will be
explained it's the name of the channel
after all fonus was a god of jealousy
and envy mainly in a romantic context do
you have a crush on someone who's
already taken thonus knows all about
that do you wish you weren't trapped in
a dead-end relationship with someone who
doesn't love you tonius understands your
plight but thonus wasn't just a reverse
Bizarro Cupid he was a literal
personification of the emotions of
jealousy and envy themselves no matter
the context if it was petty and greedy
thonus knew it all too well you would
think that this would make thonus a
prime candidate for some mythological
drama right after all the Greek gods
loved their infighting and who better to
stir up some Hara said Zeus said
arguments than a literal God of Envy
well it didn't quite work out that way
for thonus his appearances and myths
were infrequent and today he is nearly
all but forgotten reduced to a mere
three sentences on a Wikipedia page
while other figures from his era have
taken on an entirely new life in the
modern day as cultural icons like
Perseus or Hercules but no poor thonus
whose pension for jealousy and envy
backfired on him and catapulted him Into
Obscurity why did this happen it's kind
of obvious when you think about it while
other gods granted their worshippers a
good harvest or copious amounts of wine
and partying all thonus had to offer was
well the ugly side of humanity his
worshippers were far and few between
after all no one wanted their entire
life to revolve around the jealousy of
others anthonius being a personification
of Envy had an understandably difficult
time getting people to devote themselves
to him thonus was greedy and envied the
other gods so while he would accept
nothing but absolute worship from his
followers he couldn't offer much else
especially not when compared to the
Bountiful Boons a great God like Zeus or
Hera could offer and so thonus festered
an ugly God who wallowed in self-hatred
and and irrelevancy constantly living in
the shadow of the pantheon that gave him
purpose and his purpose was to remain
jealous to remain envious of those who
had what he did not a god unfit to be
worshiped whose purpose was to embody
the feelings of wanting what isn't yours
thonus is both tragic and poetic and
when the Greeks faded away so too did
thonus the Roman Empire who largely
adapted Greece's Pantheon of gods for
their own stories left no record of
bringing thonus into the mix for
centuries he was a god without a home
attempting to find a place in a changing
world thonus was angry jealous envious
and tired the forces of the universe
would call him forth in every new era
thrusting him back into the world and
forcing him to search for the sustenance
beings that were referred to as Gods fed
off of devotion but every time thonus
would find himself walking the earth
once again he would instead discover
that there was no place for him mankind
was moving on there was less and less
room for Gods with every passing Year
all the popular ones had established
themselves as Everlasting religious
figures at this point and they would
never fade away some took pleasure in
living among humans rising to power as
people of influence and fame others who
could not find a place in the world
would Fade Away Never to be revived or
worshiped ever again forgotten dead Gods
who the world long outgrew but thonus is
jealous Spirit would never allow him to
consign himself to that fate he hated
who he was and what he stood for but
that nature brought him back so many
times before it was his jealousy of the
other gods who were somehow managing to
linger beyond their Greek Heyday that
caused him to persevere he needed a
purpose one last chance to be remembered
he had struggled for centuries and this
was his last Stitch effort to be
remembered wherever he would wake up in
the modern era thonus would have to make
the most out of it and this is where
Among Us comes in in late 2020 the SCP
Foundation was just as captivated as
anyone else by the Among Us phenomenon a
game that was sweeping the globe where
players took on the roles of crew mates
on a spaceship one of which was an
impostor whose job was to secretly
murder the other players well they were
busy doing tasks that range from
scanning themselves in the medbay OR
scanning key cards in the admin room the
impostor would be lurking behind every
corner sometimes in the ship's air vents
waiting for the proper moment to strike
if a dead body was found a player could
report it and the players would then
discuss which one of them they suspected
to be the impostor the game's addictive
psychological elements and accessible
rules made it a Smash Hit but for the
foundation they were infatuated with it
for entirely different reason reasons
you see when a piece of media attains
the level of Fame that Among Us did the
foundation has to make sure to keep
their eyes on it popular media is a
prime target for anomalies the
population's collective attention on it
just seems to invite the forces of the
supernatural world to warp and distort
what we know to be familiar and this is
exactly what was happening to Among Us
for months the foundation was
documenting cases of an entity who
appeared in games of Among Us and caused
havoc in the real World these cases and
their after effects were so severe that
the foundation deemed the anomaly
significant enough to get its own file
in the database designating it under the
name SCP
5167 SCP 5167 would join games of Among
Us like any other player they would
blend in much like the impostor in the
game and play just as anyone else would
it was what happened after a player
participated in a session with SCP 516 7
that had the foundation investigating
every aspect of the game those who
played with SCP 5167 would find
themselves stricken by a severe case of
paranoia and capg grass delusion a
psychological condition in which a
victim would come to believe those
around them had been replaced with
identical imposters the severity of this
disorder varied between individuals but
some believed the delusions to such an
extent that they lashed out at those
they believed to be imposters
sometimes resulting in a homicide
naturally the foundation put two and two
together which led back to Among Us
after several months of police cases
relating to completely average
individuals suddenly striking out at
their loved ones sometimes killing them
and showing signs of capg grass delusion
the organization knew that something was
happening on an anomalous scale at first
it was difficult to make the connection
to among us but the foundation
eventually learned from interviews with
victims and an examination of of their
habits over the past few weeks they had
all played the game and through analysis
of the Among Us community's various
Trends and habits the foundation
discovered SCP
5167 an entity that was slowly gaining
notoriety within the games Community as
an almost mythological figure SCP 5167
tendency to spout long wordy rants at
other players during the game's
emergency meeting sessions position them
as an inside joke for those who
encountered them need to establish a
link between these anomalously induced
bouts of paranoia the foundation set up
a group of WebCrawler AIS to track Among
Us game sessions until SCP 5167 would
appear it was a long shot but it was one
of the many different theories on why
these victims were undergoing this level
of psychosis and if it proved to be true
then the foundation would have a solid
idea of what to do next after weeks of
nothing SCP 5167 was spotted in a game
and the foundation acted quickly to
track down the other players who played
alongside the entity naturally they
exhibited signs of paranoia and delusion
some of them only for weeks and others
for months that was enough evidence for
the foundation would later document
several other occurrences of games with
SCP 5167 resulting in these psychiatric
conditions in other players the
foundation did what they do best and
established a series of special
containment procedures that would wipe
SC P 5167 from the internet as best they
could webcrawlers were trained to take
down any mentions of the entity and if a
potential sighting was discovered the
foundation would investigate any and all
players involved in the incident anyone
affected by SCP 5167 would be held under
the guise of receiving medical treatment
for mental health issues and they would
be amnesticized completely you might be
thinking that the after effects of SCP
5167 are relatively tame compared to
what the foundation used usually deals
with but look at it this way Among Us is
a game played by millions of people if
SCP 5167 affected only a fraction of
that population it would spell total
chaos for the foundation not only that
but the amount of Bloodshed The Entity
would cause would be nothing to scoff at
as a large amount of cases dealt with
victims outright murdering anyone they
suspected to be an impostor attempting
to track down the SCP 5167 entity were
met with failure All Points of internet
access that the foundation was able to
get their hands on only led to a series
of abandoned home addresses in rural
Greece but over time things started to
change the foundation began to place
less of a concern on SCP
5167 it was almost as if the entity was
being forgotten why this letter
addressed to the SCP 5167 research team
from the sites director might clear some
things up as requested by head
researcher Abrams I've had the site 22
analysts look into the progress of SCP
5167 anomalous effects over the period
we've observed it and the results are
much as I expected when we first
discovered SCP 5167 for the sake of
argument let's say this is when SCP 5167
first came into existence the impact it
had on its victims was severe I don't
think I have to remind you of what Billy
Heath did to his family's faces but
since then almost immediately really
since that first couple of
manifestations the potency of its
effects have started to decline full
Detachment from reality became delusion
and delusion has now become paranoia and
the intensity of that paranoia is
lessening in each new case this is all
conjecture of course and shouldn't be
taken as gospel but based on what we've
observed of this anomaly thus far our
estimation is that SCP 5167 anomalous
effects will become a note by the end of
the year whether it'll keep popping up
in these video game match es is another
story though it was just as the Director
had explained SCP 5167 cases were
becoming less severe they were almost
becoming irrelevant so much so that the
foundation hypothesized that the
anomalies declining potency would lead
to its neutralization before long an
entity Fading Into irrelevance and
obscurity once more if you haven't
figured out yet maybe SCP 5167 username
will spell it out for you when the
entity joined G of Among Us it made sure
that everyone knew who it was well
everyone would know who it was if the
entity had managed to maintain any form
of popularity over the past dozen
centuries or so that's right SCP 5167
would join under the name thonus the
God's New Life had thrusted into the
modern day except this time it was
inside the game of Among Us where it was
forced to cope with the reality that the
world seemed to be more obsessed with a
trendy game than any God or mythological
figure while inside the game thonus was
one bitter individual during emergency
meetings instead of trying to figure out
if red was sus or not the God would just
yell at the Players around him one
player asked thonus what they were doing
while the rest of the crew was
performing their tasks to which thonus
poetically responded where was I I was
there when the mountains were newborn in
the oceans virginal I was there when
Gods walked among men and their wisdom
was cast down like sunlight I was there
when mankind was capable of Legends and
now I find myself in a world that has
forgotten even the taste of life even
the very concept of Life Beyond existing
from one day to the next mere
continuance where all the world is
wasted away in idle play of emotions
that once rang true I am in the world
where even the gods are forgotten their
bones washed away by time a world where
man has moved on where all the Legacy I
have left are are three sentences on
Wikipedia I thought my time had come
again I thought this could be the new me
but this is nothing let me stay dead
this time I'm tired to which the other
players responded in typical Among Us
fashion that thonus was sus he was
promptly voted as the impostor and
ejected from the airlock and so the
tragic tale of thonus came to a close a
tired obscure God who never had a place
in the World his presence in Among Us
grew less and less as the game's
popularity waned and once again he would
Fade Into Obscurity but the nature of
thonus meant that he would in some form
return again one day where or how no one
could say but as long as there was a
situation to reap Envy from a trend to
be jealous of thonus would remain
eternally doomed to suffer the fate of
being nobody's favorite God and frankly
we can't imagine this video will change
that mobile task force Edna 84 also
known by the code name and thus upon his
Crucible is on one of the strangest
missions they've ever been sent on they
sit in a darkened room beads of sweat
trickling down their brows the lights of
computer monitors shine upon their faces
they're tackling a monster that if it
escapes will literally devour all of
creation it has no fear it has no
remorse and if it isn't kept contained
by 84 it may escape and wreck havoc
across the world oh and did we mention
it's trapped in a Minecraft server you
heard us right SCP 4335 is a Cognito
hazardous extradimensional being of pure
Terror trapped inside a procedurally
generated world in the immensely popular
game Minecraft you hear about a lot of
horrifying monsters being described as
lovecraftian but only this monster is
minecraftian there's a lot that needs is
explaining here and we intend to get to
all of it but let's start with how the
foundation keeps This truly exceptional
Beast contained the foundation first
discovered SCP 4335 back in 2010 shortly
after the Alpha version of Minecraft was
released because of the online nature of
the game it's proven to be impossible to
contain 4335 externally seeing as it
isn't confined to any one physical
location shutting off the server 4335 is
found in is not an effective containment
method either as this just causes the
entity to Simply hop to a different
server the foundation's greatest fear is
that 4335 will one day make the leap out
of Minecraft and cause chaos in our
world that's why it's imperative to
draft containment procedures for SCP
4335 within the game this led to the
creation of a containment site unlike
any other site M1 the first official
Foundation site made entirely out of
money Minecraft blocks everyone who was
originally involved in the server has
been removed and amnestied since then
Elite SCP Foundation containment
Specialists and Gamers have been
constructing the perfect prison for SCP
4335 site M1 is a large Stone complex
built into the side of a mountain it has
a number of key features including a
supply area filled with materials vital
for 4335 continued containment chests
filled with books that contain CP 4335
containment procedures a few animal
farms for the purpose of breeding and
killing livestock for their meat the
entrance to a mine several chests
containing books specifically designed
for civilians to learn about
4335 if they ever breach containment and
enter the server and of course the
actual containment chamber for SCP 4335
itself which is a little more
complicated 4335 is containment chamber
is built out of several layers s all
made from iron blocks the outermost cube
is 75x 75x 75 blocks the inner cube is
55x 55x 55 blocks and the innermost cube
is 25x 25x 25 blocks creating several
levels of Defense finally one layer
within all these others which contains
the anomaly proper is made from obsidian
blocks SCP 4335 is bound into the center
of the containment chamber with a
complex mechanism the uttermost cube is
completely filled with water and several
dispensers capable of rapidly dispensing
large amounts of items in a short amount
of time line the cube the cube also
contains several mob Farms which are
devices that constantly spawn enemies
into the chamber that drop loot when
they die the chamber is essentially
designed to funnel a constant flow of
items inwards to SCP
4335 there are even contingency measures
for if SCP 4335 5 manages to breach
containment if Escape is attempted
blocks of TNT detonate above the ceiling
causing lava to pour into the chamber at
that point MTF Edna 84 are dispatched
into the server to lure 4335 back into
its containment chamber to do this they
fire a mix of fire resistant potions and
ender pearls which have teleportation
capabilities interestingly there's one
more basic method of luring SCP 4335
back into the obsidian Cube taunting and
insulting one of SCP 4335 is many
anomalous abilities is being able to
hear people through the screen and being
a proud creature it often responds to
insults by charging in to directly
Engage The insulter if SCP 4335 still
manages to breach the containment that
has been set up for it then they even
expect that it will likely soon hop into
another server at that point the goal
will shift to finding the monster and
recontain it with containment procedures
this complex and extensive it shouldn't
come as a surprise that SCP 4335 rests
firmly in the ker class what exactly is
this anomalous entity why does its
containment hinge on constantly
providing it with items and how did it
end up in Mojang's popular building and
survival game in the first place SCP
4335 in terms of physical dimensions
appears almost identical to the player
character with an all black skin it also
appears to be constantly shrouded in a
cloud of smoke particles and has long
black tendrils protruding from its back
in some respects 4335 has been compared
to two popular Creepy Pasta figures
Herobrine and the Slenderman but 4335 is
far stranger its physical body behaves
similarly to most assets native to the
game with a few peculiar anomalous
abilities we'll discuss soon handling a
SCP 4335 is an extremely delicate
process if command blocks creative mode
or server commands are ever enabled in a
server with SCP
4335 the server will instantly shut down
and SCP 4335 will move to a different
server SCP 4335 also uses its tendrils
to destroy surrounding blocks before
consuming them with each successful
consumption SCP 4335 grows and when it
reaches sufficient size it hops to a
different server as you can see keeping
us SCP 4335 contained is an uphill
battle but luckily there are two factors
on the foundation side here the first is
that SCP 4335 is immobilized while
consuming items and blocks limiting its
ability to actively Escape Foundation
forces the second factor is that SCP
4335 needs a rest period between
consuming blocks in order to grow
meaning if its consumption is constant
and continuous it isn't able to grow
these two factors have informed the
entirety of the foundation's containment
procedures around SCP
4335 it's locked into its chamber and
fed items and blocks constantly
effectively rooting it in place when SCP
4335 begins to grow the foundation also
found that the application of Ender
Pearls helps reduce it back to its
normal size however SCP 4335 does have a
method of striking back against its C CH
4335 is a virgin class multisensory
Cognito Hazard anyone viewing it without
proper training and protection may
experience distressing hallucinations
SCP 4335 is also capable of telepathic
speech with people playing on its server
and as we alluded to earlier it can also
hear any noises you make while playing
weird is a term thrown around a lot when
it comes to scps considering it's pretty
much a requirement for the foundation to
take interest in you but an all
devouring Minecraft demon that can hear
you talking through your screen is
strange even by Foundation standards MTF
Edna 84 first discovered SCP 4335 in the
single player server of Minecraft user
leaking heart three team members Jason
yelen Richard Duchamp and shilia
Freemason covertly entered the game to
investigate and potentially apprehend
the creature when leaking har first
discovered their presence on what he
thought was a private server he quickly
left a little creeped out by the sudden
intrusion thankfully the trio was still
able to locate SCP
4335 they discovered the creature hiding
inside a giant crater as though it had
impacted the Earth at considerable speed
Richard Duchamp who was the leader of
the team at the time made the mistake of
looking directly at the entity in that
moment he experienced the full force of
SCP 4335 Cognito hazardous effects he
hallucinated believe beleving that his
keyboard was melting before his eyes in
the aftermath of this incident Duchamp
was taken off the case and Jason yelson
was promoted to head of the project
things were still going to get stranger
yelson was able to open a dialogue with
the creature after containing it in a
chamber filled with lava it asked him
whether it had landed in the right
location meaning our world and yelson
informed him that had somehow fallen
into the world of Minecraft instead the
creature was at first confused and then
angry and resentful about its situation
it vowed to find its way into our world
somehow and obtain more sustenance a few
months after this The Entity managed to
breach containment and hop into another
server yelson and two others once again
managed to track it down and recontain
it but this time two civilians also
inhabiting the server were exposed to
the anomalous effects of SCP
4335 they weren't hurt but they did
appears strange and incoherent After
experiencing 43 35's Cognito hazards the
foundation tracked them down in the
aftermath and gave them amnestic
treatment 4335 was contained shortly
thereafter once again yelson came face
to face with his new foe 8 months after
being captured 4335 granted yelson
another interview from containment 4335
admitted that it almost respected yelson
and the rest of the foundation for
figuring out how to capture and contain
it so quickly in exchange it would give
the foundation something extremely
valuable information first it asked one
question of yelson how does he Define
creation yelson replied uh something
that is built and brought into this
universe by a Sapient being using other
things from this universe 4335 agreed it
went on to explain that it came from a
universe devoid of creation a dark and
unknowable Place filled with nothing but
violent random chaos its Dimension
existed directly above ours and it often
looked down at us through a dimensional
window fascinated by all the creation
below it plotted and dreamed to one day
infiltrate our reality and yelson
finally had the opportunity to ask the
magic question why though he wasn't
quite ready for the brutal honesty of
SCP
4335 reply I do not like to lie so I
will tell you now I wish to suck it dry
of the toys of whatever Force controls
your Universe destroy the light destroy
the Earth and Destroy Humanity it
reminded me of me a blubbering mass of
intelligence and order it sickens me in
ways I cannot
comprehend I hope you understand as CP
4335 was a connoisseur of creation and
it sought to devour all of it in this
moment yelson realized what an
incredibly dangerous entity he was
dealing with the only mystery was why
this creature had somehow landed in
Minecraft instead of our world which
appeared to be the only thing that saved
us but yelson didn't have time to think
4335 was about to Stage another daring
escape attempt one of its tendrils
reached out and attacked yon's player
character in that moment the real life
yelson began to hallucinate and panic
suddenly back in the game a series of
abnormally tall slender black figures
appeared and began deconstructing the
containment chamber around SCP
4335 it had somehow summoned new minions
into the game to assist in this
Containment Breach Jason yelson entered
Cognito Hazard quarantine following this
incident and was removed from the
project and he wasn't the only one
affect Ed by this incident following the
first appearance of these long dark
figures players across the globe began
to experience them appearing in their
own games the foundation managed to find
a solution they contacted Mojang and had
the creatures patched into the game
during the next update as a new
non-anomalous entity which seemed to
stop 4335 from being able to use them as
its own tools they're now known as the
Enderman and are beloved among fans for
being one of the creepier enemies to
this day containment efforts continue
for SCP
4335 but there's only one question left
why did The Entity fall into Minecraft
rather than our world the file posits
the most likely answer because 4335
defines creation as elements made by
Sapient beings in Minecraft the most
popular game in the world that the
height of 4335 is power everything that
exists is the product of code made by
humans creation is truly abundant there
as for our world in SCP 4335 is extra
dimensional eyes there is no creation no
intelligent design no soothing piano
soundtrack just frightening chaotic
Randomness which is too unlike its own
Dimension so even if SCP 4335 ever did
arrive in our reality it would likely be
disappointed by how little there is to
eat the thin pale humanoid anomaly had
just found itself in Minecraft of all
places the all to familiar whale of a
mergency alarms rang out through the
corridors of the foundation facility it
had happened again another containment
breach of course the on-site Personnel
were more than familiar with the
protocols for a situation like this so
well versed in what to do during an
emergency that it had become second
nature whether they were research staff
evacuating for their own safety or
security teams moving in to recapture
the escaped anomaly and get the
situation under control everyone was
moving like they had been programmed
muscle memory taking over the loose
anomaly was none other than scp096 all
Foundation Personnel were alerted and
reminded not to look directly at the
creature there was just one problem they
couldn't look even if they'd ignored
their order to try nobody could because
the shy guy was nowhere to be found well
nowhere in the real world at least this
whole situation bizarre even by
Foundation standards had all started
with an experiment involving a member of
the Disposable d-class personel yet
another dangerous convict serving one of
several life sentences now being used as
an Expendable human lab rat for the
foundation's often Sinister purposes the
experiment in question was an attempt to
further test the limitation of scp096
abilities by now the foundation had done
extensive research into the creature
known as as the shy guy they knew its
particular brand of anomalous qualities
were triggered when anyone looked
directly at it being observed would
instantaneously send scp096 into an
uncontrollable rage State causing it to
pursue its Observer until they were no
longer standing scp096 was known to be
able to travel at speed so relentless it
was pretty much impossible to stop one
moment it was sobbing and screeching in
its cell having just been observed and
minutes later the wide jawed long limed
monster was standing behind whoever had
seen it making its screaming face the
image its victim took to the Grave with
them Foundation researchers knew that
scp096 is Rage State could be triggered
by as little as someone seeing the
slightest hint of a creature even if the
shy guy had been captured as a tiny
Speck in the background of a photograph
it would come after anyone whose eyes so
much as glanced over that Speck it also
didn't matter how far away the Observer
was scp096 could not be outrun it could
track down anyone wherever they were in
the world but what if a person who had
observed the shy guy was no longer in
the world the experiment had taken a lot
of trial and error after all digitizing
a human being and transforming their
entire Consciousness into code was no
easy task but the foundation wasn't
above breaking more than a few eggs to
make an omelet especially when those
eggs were the brains of a few d-class
Personnel actually the first test
objects turned out more scrambled or
fried certainly overdone given the
amount of smoke coming from their ears
but eventually the research team had
perfected the device they dubbed the
neural harness a headset that could
translate a person's mind into pure
digital code their Consciousness would
be extracted from their body leaving
their physical form an empty shell while
a digital copy of them was able to
Traverse the local on-site computer
network of course the foundation wasn't
about to let a digitized d-class run a
muck with their systems so their coding
experts wrote a number of specialized
parameters into their successful test
subject now the digital d-class could be
programmed to follow the foundation
directive from his perspective it was
like he was floating through cyberspace
towards the system that the foundation
had directed him to a surveillance
camera inside scp096 cell that usually
remained inactive but not today the
camera blinked to life as soon as the
d-class is code-based consciousness
reached it and through it he was able to
observe SC scp096 sitting against the
far wall of its containment chamber
gently whimpering and walking back and
forth that is until the creature felt
that same familiar sensation of being
watched it stood up enraged wailing
uncontrollably as the d-class watched
from within the camera then a split
second later scp096 appeared to Blink
out of existence it hadn't work the
experiment had failed and the the
digital d-class began to panic before
the foundation coders could stop him he
frantically scoured the local network
for anything some kind of Escape Route
back into the real world maybe he
thought if he could get back into his
body it wouldn't count technically his
digital self was separate from his
physical form so he might get out of SCP
96's clutches on a technicality but it
was impossible his body was already
burned out by the neural harness there
was no way for the d-class to transfer
himself back there was only one option
left hide and as it turned out someone
had forgotten to uninstall a certain
building game from a computer in one of
the foundation doctor's offices the DCL
classes digitized mind zapped him into
Minecraft from his point of view it was
like he existed within the game itself
he did a computerized equivalent of
breathing a sigh of relief only to take
back all those ones and zeros in a
horrified gasp as he noticed a tall wiry
framed figure before him it hadn't
worked as scp096 had still managed to
follow him into Minecraft even in a
world of computer code the shy guy was
able to dispatch its digital Observer
quite easily and what had once been a
living human mind in the form of binary
code was quickly deleted but that's when
scp096 started to take notice of its
surroundings but the most recent person
to see it gone it had the chance to
actually take in where it was the bright
rays of warm light coming down from a
cube-shaped sun reveal a welcoming
landscape all around constructed
entirely from cubes it fascinated scp096
instilling a kind of childlike Wonder in
the shy guy the likes of which it hadn't
experienced since well since it couldn't
remember when rather than leaving
instantly reappearing in its containment
chamber scp096 made the conscious
decision to start exploring there was a
mountainous biome surrounding scp096
Stony spires reaching up towards a clear
sky with a waterfall cascading its way
down the nearest of them at the foot of
the mountains was the opening of a cave
which the shyy found itself wandering
towards the light from the sun while a
pleasant and welcoming change to the
surroundings it was used to was a little
harsh on scp096 is sunken eyes so
instead it began to gravitate towards
the shadowy confines of the caves not
unlike the usual darkness of its
containment chamber back at the
foundation traversing through long
winding Cor Doors of Stone as CP 096
found itself having to bend down to
avoid hitting its head on the Cave's low
ceiling obviously this formation of
Rocky blocks had informed with someone
of the shy guys's height in mind there
was a low Warm Glow coming from the
farthest side of the tunnel and the thin
creature made its way closer and closer
despite the stone walls around it
feeling like a tighter confinement than
its cell approaching the source of the
light scp096 was relieved that the cave
opened out into a more spacious area the
cramp tunnel giving way to an expansive
chamber that lay within the heart of the
mountain the warm orangey glow that had
been coming from a flowing stream of
boiling hot lava that seemed to trickle
down from somewhere above creating a
deadly fiery pool directly in the shy
guys's path but just before it could
turn back and leave the cave through the
way he came scp096 sense that familiar
feeling of something observing him
across the lava pool on the other side
was a creature comprised of a green Cube
for a head with a long armless cuboid
body and four cubed feet if it had been
present in the real world it might have
been made out of leaves like a living
shrub it was staring directly at the shy
guy from across the lava only for the
strange newcomer to disappear a moment
later the creeper hissed before it
realized that scp096 had leaped up
behind it to land a fatal blow but
little did the infamously anxious
anomaly realize that the sentient shrub
wasn't done there was a colossal boom
that caused scp096 to stagger backwards
whimpering at the sudden loud explosion
and the pain that had accompanied it the
creeper had blown itself to Pieces but
in doing so had left a lasting injury
that caused scp096 considerable
discomfort as it began limping towards
the cave that led out the opposite side
of the mountain despite its injury the
shy guy was still able to move with
relative ease and the further it went
the more it seemed to gradually heal
however it was as it stepped out once
more into the sunlight that the creature
realized just how hungry it was back in
the real world it hadn't eaten for
several hours and surprisingly even
while accidentally stuck in digitized
form the hunger mechanics of Minecraft
were having an effect on scp096 the shy
guy started searching around for
anything that could prove to satiate its
hunger there was a Grove of trees not
far so scp096 lumbered to take take a
closer look it couldn't be certain but
it felt there was at least a slim chance
that there were apples growing amongst
the leaves but even at the anomaly's own
elongated height it couldn't simply
reach up to pick them however it was
while swiping its arms up at the tree
that the shy guy swung its Fist and
knocked at the tree trunk to the
creature's surprise it was able to chip
away at the wood with its hands punching
at the tree until the trunk had been
reduced to a collection of wooden blocks
that the shy guy was able to collect and
sure enough some red apples dropped from
the leaves above enough to quell the
hunger that scp096 was feeling at least
for the time being nearby something was
moving through the trees it was yet to
lock eyes on scp096 but the second it
did the mob would surely have sealed its
own fate as it moved around minding its
own business the tall figure overheard
the sounds of the shy guy eating and its
attention was drawn to where the
creature was standing enjoying an apple
sensing that it had been seen as as CP
096 turned and locked eyes with the
entity it was perhaps the only other
being in Minecraft that was a similar
height and stature to the anomaly itself
in fact the pair were strikingly similar
before scp096 could carry out its usual
method of attack the Enderman suddenly
teleported out of view but it was too
late now both it and the shy guy had
looked at the other's face both had been
provoked and were compelled to react in
exactly the same way just as SCP Z 96
entered its rage State the Enderman 2
opened its mouth and began to shake
making loud lengthy sounds not to
similar to the shy guys's own angered
screams but something profoundly strange
happened next scp096 and the Enderman
kept attempting to pursue one another
appearing in a new location within the
Minecraft world neither one getting
close enough to the other they teleport
only for the other to teleport away the
moment they saw each other each trying
to catch one another but always staying
one step behind this rapid Chase almost
became a strange ongoing sort of
teleporting dance between scp096 and the
Enderman at first the shy guy had been
compelled to attack the Enderman like it
was with any who looked directly at it
but as they appeared and disappeared
from place to place the creature started
to feel an odd kinship with this shadowy
fellow it was so used to being
frightened and alone to its overwhelming
feelings of insecurity and self-loathing
that the Simplicity of just traversing
the open world with a creature very
alike itself in many ways it had all
come as a welcome change scp096 found it
therapeutic even and before long was
following the Enderman not out of any
intention to do it harm but just to feel
for a little while like it had a friend
just a little bit longer as scp096
thought welcoming the enjoyment it felt
playing this game of Minecraft the year
was 2015 Lewis Joseph and Sydney were
like a lot of kids their age which is to
say 11 years old they secretly stay up
past their bedtime watching scary videos
on the internet when their moms and dads
think they're sleeping they go to school
every day and daydream about all the fun
things they're going to do when that
school bell finally rings at the end of
the day and of course they play a lot
and we mean a lot of Minecraft whenever
they're not at school hanging out at the
local par Park and filming goofy Tik Tok
videos or watching those AFF
forementioned scary videos on the
internet there's a good chance that
they'll be online together logging a few
extra hours building bases digging big
holes or playing survival mode and
seeing how long they can last against
the onslaught of mobs but there's one
particular Pursuit they have while
playing Minecraft together that takes up
the majority of their playtime one ktic
Quest that drives them forward despite
all the naysayers and doubters tracking
down and finding the legendary Minecraft
creepy pasta entity Herobrine for those
who weren't around on the internet back
then creepy pastas like Herobrine were
all the rage like any video game the new
frontier of Minecraft with all of its
procedurally generated Landscapes felt
like it held new Mysteries and Mysteries
are equal parts exciting and frightening
after all who really knows what's going
on behind a closed door herob was a
Minecraft specific little urban legend
stories told of a default Minecraft skin
with early white eyes manifesting in the
game even in Solo matches and
terrorizing players one internet sleuth
who looked into the mystery of Herobrine
claimed it to be the haunted soul of the
Dead Brother of Minecraft's Creator
Marcus Pon also known as notch in the
years since the legend first started
Notch himself has come forward and
disavowed the claim saying that that in
fact he didn't even have a brother and
never had so the rumors were completely
baseless but as we here at the SCP
Foundation know the truth has never
gotten in the way of a good story so
Lewis Joseph and Sydney were happy to
remain Believers as long as they could
keep having fun chasing alleged digital
ghosts how could any of these boys know
that in the midst of their fun they'd
run into a real monster amidst
Minecraft's blocky Vistas it was a
school night like any other when they
made that first fateful Expedition it
was 7:15 p.m. and the boys were all in
their shared server Lewis had chicken
tenders Joseph had chicken nuggets and
Sydney who'd eaten his dinner earlier
than the others was snacking on a pack
of Skittles they' all outfitted their
characters with full diamond armor with
diamond swords to match because Joseph
had somehow convinced the others that
diamonds were ghost prooof he read it on
the internet he claimed together the
three boys had made made themselves an
impressive Minecraft castle to be the
base of their Herobrine hunting
operations a safe haven surrounded by
high stone walls and MOB repelling
torches to keep them safe if ever they
got a little too spooked while playing
though playing was perhaps too mild the
word for it in the minds of these three
boys they were doing extremely important
investigative work after all if they
managed to actually find Herobrine
themselves they would be creepy pasta
Legend
and wouldn't that be worth all the hours
upon hours of rigorous Mining and
crafting they'd been methodical in their
search scoping out different corners of
the map and canvasing them together
searching high and low and then marking
said area off their checklist it was a
level of consideration and thought that
their parents and teachers had long
wished the boys would put into their
home or schoolwork but alas seeing as
none of the homework was find Herobrine
they really weren't that interested
today they were searching an area deep
in the misty forests in the dead of
night they fought off a few spiders and
sword wielding skeletons thankfully no
creepers a man and kept foraging on into
the darkness it's so creepy out here L
said over his headset why do we have to
come out here at night it it's way more
dangerous with all the mobs the night is
like the perfect time for ghosts Sydney
retorted you think a ghost is going to
start hanging around in the middle of
the day no way it's got to be at night
man and LS simply could not argue with
such incredibly Sound Logic they forged
on doing their typical methodical search
for any phenomenon that one might
generously be able to describe as
supernal so you can only imagine the
excitement coursing through them when
Joseph discovered a strange dark cave
that looked as though it had no business
being there while each held their own
private reservations they all knew what
they needed to do go inside and
investigate as they entered the cave a
few strange realizations occurred to
them such as the the fact that there
were seemingly no mobs down here a cave
in the dead of night surely there should
be some enemies right plus the typical
lighting implements like torches and
lanterns didn't seem to offer the same
kind of Illumination that they normally
would it was almost like the darkness
was more oppressive here more tangible
there was undeniably something Eerie
about the whole setup that much couldn't
be denied you guys see anything LS asked
no Joseph said sounding oddly cautious
as though he sensed something strange
was on the horizon something that
perhaps these boys shouldn't see yeah I
haven't seen anything either Sydney
chimed in maybe we should Joseph
screamed and the two others turned their
Minecraft Avatars to look at him
Joseph's character had bumped into
something some stranger in the cave an
NPC design that looked oddly realistic
for something inhabiting the
purposefully lowii blocky world of
Minecraft it seemed to have a dark furry
body with a can skull-like face bearing
a pair of milky white eyes that seemed
to stare off into nothingness was this
another mob maybe something added in the
latest patch if so why wasn't it
attacking what is that thing leis asked
over his headset I don't know Joseph
replied it's so creepy though suddenly a
message appeared on the screen as though
it had been typed and sent by another
player a player with the username Mal o
the message read hey that isn't very
very nice you shouldn't judge on
appearances kid that certainly gave them
pause so many things about this didn't
make sense it had all the Hallmarks of
an NPC but apparently it understood
their voices and could send messages it
clearly wasn't actually another player
in a conventional sense but it didn't
attack like your typical mob none of the
boys could really make sense of what
they were dealing with here are you a
hacker Sydney asked no Mal o tyed back
back I'm just lonely and a long way from
home it's nice to have your company down
here though I don't get visitors often
have you heard of Herobrine LS asked mow
typed back is he a friend of yours you
should introduce him to me I love making
new friends the three boys were in some
regards rather mature and polite for
their ages and so remained civil with
this bizarre mysterious figure it was
curious and inquisitive asking them
questions about their school lives and
their friends it did seem earnestly
happy for their company so it didn't
give any of them the sense that it was a
threat as night Drew on and the boys
respective parents told them it was time
to log off and get some shed ey mow
finally typed I've really enjoyed
hanging out with you kids come back and
visit me again tomorrow if you don't
I'll come visit you instead none of the
kids picked up on the probably rather
obvious stranger danger Vibes of this
message and instead they went to bed
excited and curious the next day they
met up on the playground for a kind of
State of the Union on the strange
phenomenon they had encountered the
night before do you think it has
anything to do with Herobrine leis asked
forget Herobrine Sydney replied
eliciting gasp from the two others all
the other people have Herobrine we have
something better something only we've
discovered we've got Malo later that
night Joseph who was probably the most
studious of the group tried to do a
little background research on Mal o
everything seemed to turn up dead ends
aside from one slightly Shady looking
app called Malo version
1.0.0 its description read never settle
for those awkward feelings of being
alone ever again Malo is an exciting and
interactive experience that will keep
you engaged and intrigued the anxiety of
social situations can be nerve-wracking
but just after a few hours of Malo you
will soon forget all about those painful
emotions of disappointment be part of
the new cze that is quickly becoming the
next social substitute remember the more
you participate the more Mal o will
engage you your experience is completely
up to you absolutely no ads enjoy weird
so unless the thing they encountered on
Minecraft was some kind of weird viral
marketing campaign for the app it was
probably just a coincidence maybe it was
a popular character from Japan or
something by the way for the next
several days the boys honored their
promise they'd visit Mal o in the cave
every night and chat trying to tactfully
get more information out of it though
the best they could get on the entity's
origin was the cryptic statement I'm not
usually here but everyone wants a
vacation once in a while don't they we
can't just spend our whole life on a
phone they'd become so acclimated to Mal
o over the days that they forgot what
the entity had said to them the very
first day they met come back and visit
me again tomorrow if you don't I'll come
visit you instead but on the day that
they didn't come and visit Malo because
Miss Grayson had sent a particularly
challenging ing piece of English
homework they received a frightening
reminder that very night they all
started receiving strange texts on their
phones as you can probably expect they
were all photographs each and everyone
depicting some regular haunt that the
boys all liked to frequent with one
addition Mal O's grinning skull face
hiding somewhere in the image like some
kind of demented parody of where's Waldo
the strangeness of this new development
left all the boys shaken and they hopped
back onto Minecraft as quickly as
possible to go find and talk to Malo in
its cave however this time the cave was
empty and Malo was nowhere to be seen
But the Tex still didn't stop they'd
come in so frequently with malow getting
closer to home literally in each one the
boys thought about telling their parents
but would their parents believe them
they probably lump Mal Owen with the
same Tall Tales of childhood imagination
as Herobrine and write it off as bored
kids playing a prank even though in this
this case it was anything but more
photos arrived in these ones Mal o was
right outside each of the children's
homes lurking watching in some of the
photos they could see themselves in the
windows going about their evening
business having no idea of the creature
lurking just outside none of the boys
felt like playing Minecraft that night
it wasn't fun anymore instead they shut
themselves up in their rooms closed and
locked their windows and pulled down the
blinds after check under the beds with
flashlights of course but still more
photos came in all depicting Mal o
getting closer and closer and closer
right about the time they were wondering
whether the scratching on the outside of
their bedroom door was real or just a
figment of their imagination another
dark irony had occurred to them all this
time trying to find something
Supernatural and in the very end
something Supernatural had instead found
them while want an anomaly of your own
check out SCP swag.com for highquality
SCP merch video games have come a long
way over the years we've gone from the
days of Atari and pong to Virtual
Reality headsets ps5s and massive
multiplayer online games where you can
fight horror movie villains or wage war
in a fantasy land you can mine virtual
minerals and avoid creepers in Minecraft
compete against people all over the
world in fortnite and do whatever it is
people do in Roblox blcks games used to
be a pixelated hero battling Blobby
monsters with no discernible facial
features and now they have Graphics so
detailed you can see the freckles on a
protagonist's face and each individual
blade of grass but there's one thing
that hasn't changed no matter how much
progress games may make whenever a shiny
new console comes out everyone wants to
get their hands on it it was Christmas
season in
1986 Walk Like an Egyptian by the
Bengals was at the top of the chart
Eddie Murphy's The Golden Child was the
number one movie in America and hundreds
of thousands of kids were riding to
Santa and begging their parents for one
thing the Nintendo Entertainment System
the NES was an 8-bit home video game
console and the only place to Journey
Through the land of Hyrule in The Legend
of Zelda or help Samos hunt space
pirates in Metroid but with such an
extreme demand for the system stores
were selling out all over the country
anyone who didn't beat the crowds was
doomed to disappoint their kids with
socks with less flashy toys like dolls
or tiny plastic trucks or with boring
non-electric violence-free board games
well board games are only violence-free
if you're not playing Monopoly but back
to
1986 Beverly Harrington was a single mom
doing her best to provide for her son
Jason and give him the Christmas he
deserved she had been picking up extra
shifts at the local Diner making sure to
save up all the extra money for a real
Christmas tree from the farm just out of
town for a beautiful honey baked ham and
of course for presents she knew that
though he was a shy kid and would never
demand it Jason desperately wanted to
find an NES under the tree on Christmas
morning she got so absorbed in her work
so exhausted from the extra shifts and
trying to make everything perfect that
she forgot to do her actual shopping
until the very last minute she woke up
the morning of December 24th with a
start her heart jumping into her throat
she hadn't picked up Jason's present yet
she threw on her coat and rushed out
into the snowy streets making her way to
the store and saying a silent prayer
that they would still have one more NES
in stock lucky for her they did less
lucky two parents were already wrestling
for it fighting each other with a raw
animalistic Rage of two wolves competing
for the same piece of meat if she tried
to grab it and join in she could get
hurt or the console could break apart
she asked an employee if they had any in
the back but she already knew the answer
from the exhausted look in his eyes
there were no more in the back there
were no more in town nor the next town
over or the next town over from that not
only would she have to get Jason's
present at the very last minute but she
would also have to get him something he
didn't even want he would smile and
thank her but she knew how sad it would
make him to go back to school and hear
his friends bragging about their
Christmases she shoved her hands into
the pockets of her coat and began her
slow sad March back through the snow
trying to come up with what to do next
then something caught her eye a brightly
colored sign reading Wonder taining toys
beneath it it was a storefront she had
never seen before and right there in the
window a video game console it wasn't
the NES not exactly but it looked so
much like it she couldn't help herself
she had to go inside and get a better
look the store was filled with toys
games and puzzles they were all inviting
with Vivid packaging and labels
depicting children having fun but she
had never seen any of them before
perhaps it was a new brand and she was
one of the first people to happen upon
the store it seemed odd for a toy store
to open this close to Christmas rather
than taking advantage of the shopping
season and opening earlier in the year
but she couldn't dwell on that not when
she was this close to a solution toward
the back of the store she spotted the
video game console from the window the
label read pretendo so the resemblance
to the NES was no coincidence this
console was int Ended as a knockoff of
some kind she asked the sales clerk a
man with a strangely wide unmoving smile
if the console was capable of running
Nintendo games you bet your bottom
dollar he replied we don't carry those
here though but can I interest you in
some of our Wonder tainment Originals we
have all kinds of games here and they're
just as good or your money back there's
a whole world inside each and every one
it wasn't what she'd set out to buy but
this was clearly the best thing Beverly
was going to find this close to the
holiday she paid the man for for the
pretendo console and a selection of the
store's most popular video games he even
gift WRA it for her in a colorful box
with a shiny red bow on top the next
morning Jason and Beverly sat in the
living room sipping cocoa and opening
presents together she started small with
a classic pair of new wolf socks and
worked her way up to the big box in the
corner as Jason tore the paper off his
eyes lit up with Glee thank you Mom
thank you he gave her a huge hug then
looked at her with nearly manic
excitement can I play it now can I she
laughed and promised that after he
helped her clean up the wrapping paper
he could play his new games she was just
so glad he was happy with it he didn't
care that it wasn't the name brand
console he knew that this gift was
special so she was perfectly glad to let
him enjoy it and she could get started
on that ham for later Jason plugged in
his brand new pretendo and looked
through the games his mom had picked out
for him there was farmtastic Farming
Simulator Historical house Hunter magic
Wizard Quest super fighter and one
simply called spooky it was emblazened
with the image of a cartoon ghost in
front of an abandoned cabin and it
piqued Jason's interest he always loved
scary stories and legends about ghosts
and Things That Go Bump in the night he
decided that this would be the first
game that he would play he placed the
cartridge in the console and hit the
power button to turn it on as he
clutched the controller in his hands he
began to notice something strange his
room once decorated in posters of his
favorite movies turned dark the light
green Walls became rotting wood and for
lack of a better way to describe it the
entire world's resolution began to shift
if the world around him had Graphics
they were getting worse he could no
longer see the screen depicting the
game's main menu and in fact the console
itself had vanished somehow he was
standing in the Haunted Cabin from the
cover of the game he looked down at his
hands and found the controller still
there so not everything had changed
before he could think anymore about this
strange new place he found himself in he
heard the sound of ominous music
seemingly coming from nowhere after a
moment he realized why the sound of its
Melody filled him with dread it was the
kind of music that always played in a
game when an enemy was getting close he
had to move he took a step forward and
moved through the space as if it was a
real house for the time being it was
somehow he was inside the game which
meant the ghost was coming for him soon
he pressed a button on the controller to
activate a flashlight and followed its
beam through the darkened cabin as he
walked looking for clues or any object
he could interact with he could hear the
music getting louder whatever was coming
it was getting closer the flashlights
beam illuminated a scrap of paper on a
small table he moved to take a closer
look and could just barely make out what
it said they hide in the darkness find
the exit don't stop moving he heard
heard a sound behind him and the music
reached a deafening volume he Whirled
around and saw nothing but the hall in
front of him bending around a corner he
knew from the heavy feeling in the pit
of his stomach and the music that
threatened to rupture his eardrums that
there was something horrible waiting for
him around that corner he froze for a
moment then remembered the Letter's
words of warning don't stop moving he
took a step towards the corner then
another and another he shown the light
of the flashlight around around the
corner but there was nothing there no
ghost no monster nothing and then he
felt it a chill on the back of his neck
he Whirled around and there it was the
Ghost of the cabin it was so much bigger
than it had looked before wispy white
form stretching up to the ceiling from
wall to wall its wide dark eyes and
gaping ma of a mouth inches from his own
face he screamed and instinctively swung
the flashlight at the Spirit cutting
through it with a beam of light the
ghost let out a shriek and shrank away
from the glow that was it he just needed
to keep the light on it and the ghost
couldn't hurt him Jason was so thrilled
by this little victory that he didn't
even notice the Boss music starting to
play again growing louder and louder he
didn't see the movement out of the
corner of his eye the Silvery pale
figure of a woman stepping out of a
portrait on the wall all he felt was a
sudden overwhelming cold like ice in his
veins and then everything went black he
opened his eyes back in his bedroom
looking at a dark screen with the words
game over written in dripping red font
he couldn't tell for a moment if that
had been real or a dream but either way
he only wanted to do one thing tell his
mom Beverly listened to her son's story
and couldn't help but write it off as
the overactive imagination of a child
but still she humored him and agreed to
try the console for herself and see what
happened choosing at random she selected
farmas stick and pressed play all of a
sudden she felt the heat of the sun on
her face heard the mooing of cows and
smelled fresh cut hay she was steering a
tractor through a wide open field where
a moment ago she had been standing in
her house in the dead of winter Jason
shut off the game pulling her back into
reality and as Beverly gasped in shock
Jason said best present ever
unfortunately for Jason word was already
spreading about the pretendo all the way
to the SCP Foundation the console and
all other consoles that the foundation
could track down were seized and
designated SCP 591 SCP 591 is a line of
video game consoles originally developed
as a counterfeit of the Nintendo
Entertainment System before being bought
and distributed by Dr Wonder tainment a
toy company responsible for a wide
variety of anomalous objects contained
by the foundation over the years the
console is capable of playing NES titles
as well as games from Dr wain's original
lineup of 8bit games many of which the
foundation has in its possession as well
some of the titles in the SCP
foundation's Library include but are not
limited to Arcade shooter wam platformer
Dusky adventures in stateand survival
horror game you can do that on
television puzzle game World War I Ace
trench digger music racing game lead
Zeppelin Air Racers fighting games super
kit karate and super kit karate 2010 and
the educational game Reading Rainbow sit
and listen whenever one of the official
doctor wondertainment cartridges is
inserted into the console and activated
it results in a localized CK class
reality restructuring scenario which
rearranges reality in the immediate area
to resemble the game's setting the
player inside of the game's affected
radius will take on the role of the
game's protagonist and navigate the
events of the game until either they win
or the console is deactivated don't
worry this isn't one of those if you die
in the game you die in real life
scenarios if the player happens to be a
less than Adept gamer they will simply
respawn or start at the beginning of the
game like any video game character would
that doesn't however mean that SCP 591
isn't dangerous like any piece of
vintage technology the components of the
pretendo system have degraded over time
their functionality steadily decreasing
for an ordinary game console this would
be a simple inconvenience something that
would impact the quality of the graphics
or responsiveness of the controls it
would be annoying and maybe eventually
unplayable but otherwise harmless for
the pretendo however this degradation
has had catastrophic events when a game
cartridge is inserted into SCP 591 there
is now a chance of the CK class reality
restructuring scenario going wrong and
resulting in a ZK class reality failure
scenario instead essentially instead of
just transporting the player into the
world of the Game reality will crumble
in the designated area and the laws of
time time space and physics will be bent
or even broken while the CK class
scenarios dissipate as soon as the
console is deactivated the ZK class
scenarios refuse to play by the rules
they remain in place wherever they first
manifested seemingly permanently the ZK
class scenarios were first observed
during play testing by the research
staff assigned to SCP 591 after learning
about the nature of the pretendo game
system Dr Furukawa has volunteered as a
test subject specifically requesting
that he'd be given the chance to play
the drct wondertainment title The Legend
of swordmaster because quote it just
looks really cool this particular game
came with not just the cartridge but a
special sword-shaped controller to be
used during the sword fight sequences Dr
Furukawa stepped into the containment
cell where one instance of SCP 591 had
been placed with his chosen game
cartridge and controller waiting for him
as soon as he inserted the cartridge
into the console and pressed the start
button the room around him began to
transform reality itself warping and
reshaping to fit the world of the game
fluorescent lights and stark white walls
were replaced by pixelated trees and a
winding Cobblestone path leading to a
massive Stone Castle the first enemy a
knight in black armor leapt into frame
and Dr Furukawa raised his sword ready
for combat but before he had a chance to
deal the first blow it became clear that
something wasn't right the enemy Knight
suddenly disappeared glitching out of
sight the Cobblestone slowly began to
drift into the air and so did Dr frwa
just as suddenly as he lifted off he
dropped back to the ground with a heavy
thud gravity was rapidly fluctuating and
he could scarcely keep his balance in
front of him he could see random cubic
structures popping up out of nowhere
made of wood Stone and ice and the game
he called out desperately pull the plug
someone please outside one of the
researchers watching The Experiment cut
the power to the console but nothing
happened the world refused to return to
normal security officers entered the
area and attempted to remove Dr Furukawa
but found that his body still resembled
an 8-bit video game character when they
attempted to drag him out of the ZK
class zone he cried out in pain as his
body began to dissolve into static they
had turned off the console but they were
unable to pull him out the rest of the
research team horrified by what they had
witnessed began to take measurements of
the reality failure scenario from
outside of the room the area now
displayed a complete absence of
naturally occurring radiation including
cosmic background radiation there was
also evidence of time dilation reduction
of light speed and the gravity
fluctuations that Dr Furukawa had first
noticed with no way to remove futakawa
from this broken reality the area would
have to be sealed off and he would be
left inside there was no other option so
they constructed a concrete Dome around
the testing site and relocated the
remaining instant es of SCP 591 from
that point on testing was only conducted
using DCL classes no matter how much
research staff loved video games or how
vehemently they insisted that they were
quote willing to roll the dice they were
barred from testing and encouraged to
pick up a VR headset for a much lower
risk immersive gaming experience over
the years of testing following the Dr
phawa incident four more ZK class
scenarios were created and contained
some of the individuals survived the
incident but were physically altered so
greatly that they would not be able to
survive outside of the ZK class reality
failure the only people who survived
were unable to readjust to their lives
continuing to live as the main character
of the game that they were playing at
this point testing was officially
suspended indefinitely due to not only
the loss of human life but also the
unpredictable and highly dangerous
nature of the damage being done to
reality on such a grand scale all
instances of SCP 591 confiscated by the
foundation are kept in a storage
containment Vault kept separate from any
civilians or their infrastructure by a
distance of at least 500 M it is also
kept separate from other Foundation
controlled containment facilities unless
it is being used for official approved
testing by level three staff it is to
remain deactivated at all times any ZK
class scenarios created by an instance
of SCP 591 will be contained via the
construction of a closed concrete Dome
and given the designation of sector W
number sectors W1 through W5 the
currently existing ZK class scenarios
are monitored remotely and kept highly
classified any Personnel or test
subjects located inside one of these
sectors will remain there indefinitely
and be officially considered Lost In
Action any additional instances of SCP
591 located in civilian stores
households or any public place are to be
removed and contained indefinitely as
the years have gone by testing has
indicated a steady increase in the rate
of ZK class scenarios being generated
from a CK class scenario where it was
only a 1% chance there is now a 32%
chance according to wainman company
records seized during a foundation raid
of one of their toy factories there are
still plenty of SCP 591 instances out
there in the world just waiting for some
unsuspecting gamer to fire them up and
get lost in the story literally if the
documents found are accurate there are
around 243 consoles and 1300 consoles
still in circulation these Also may or
may not include a pocket pretendo model
that was developed as a prototype but
never officially released on the market
if it was and the chaos of the pretendo
system is available in a portable form
well it's best not to think about that
for too long the foundation is doing its
best to track down the remaining
pretendo systems but there is no way to
know for sure what distant corners of
the world they've made their way to so
when you're picking up a shiny new game
console or a nostalgic vintage model to
Rel live some of your favorite childhood
memories with take an extra close look
at the label and make sure you're
getting the real thing because if you're
not careful it just might be game over
for many Avid video game fans those who
just can't get enough of grinding away
for hours on quests battling endless
enemies and exploring infinite Virtual
Worlds Landing a job as a gameplay
tester seems like the perfect
opportunity doing your favorite thing in
the world and getting paid to do it well
that's the dream plus the added benefit
of seeing how the sausage gets made of
getting access to a game still in
development and suggesting ways it can
be improved think of all the gaming
disasters that might have been avoided
with a few more play testers in the room
looking at you Fallout New Vegas and
your NPCs with the spinning
heads well One Gamer had the same
thought a young man by the name of Danny
wheeler when he spotted an ad seeking
beta play testers for an in development
RPG from an upand cominging indie game
Studio he jumped at the chance to apply
the pay wasn't amazing but it was
definitely a better gig than his current
job at the local convenience store
Hawking energy drinks to snarky teens
and counting down the hours until he
could get back home kick up his feet and
get away from it all with a controller
in his hand but sometimes things that
seem too good to be true actually are at
first Danny had a perfectly enjoyable
time testing the game it was standard
RPG fantasy F and though he made sure to
inform the developers that he found the
steampunk aesthetic to be a little bit
played out at this point there was
nothing at all notable about it it was
fine but the development team kept going
on and on about the Tactical heuristic
algorithms and how the game was meant to
learn the more the player played so Dany
was instructed to log as many hours of
this exceedingly average game as
possible he sat at his desk for hours
sipping on an extra- llarge soda and
clicking away fighting Orcs SC goblins
and more slowly the difficulty began to
increase and the game started to grow on
him a bit he even developed a favorite
character to play as the Rogue with his
stealth and proficiency for close-range
combat the more he played as the Rogue
however the more he started to notice
the game's characters behaving
differently enemies were attacking him
with ranged weapons from far away they
were setting traps to ruin his character
stealthy approach and catch him in the
ACT then the game started to glitch a
lot to the point of becoming nearly
unplayable enemies would fall to the
ground as if Dead when he hadn't dealt
them a single blow as he started to walk
his characters away from them they would
suddenly spring back to life and strike
before he could even think about a
defense if he didn't know any better he
could swear the game's characters were
deliberately trying to trick him it only
got more frustrating from there with
enemies making sudden loud sounds to
catch him off guard and startle him out
of concentration and other characters
staring down the barrel of the camera
with serious unblinking eyes as if they
could see him through his monitor one
day he fired up the game to see that its
characters somehow had rearranged
various torches to spell out you'll
never amount to anything Danny your dad
was right it took a ton of torches and
Danny couldn't help but take it
personally that was the last straw he
returned the game to the studio and
resigned from his position he got enough
insults working in customer service he
didn't need to take that kind of talk
from a video game though he didn't know
it Dany got out not a moment too soon
other play testers were not as lucky
particularly One Man Who Would sadly
lose his life as Danny intuited this was
no ordinary video game it was unusual
enough to draw the attention of the SCP
Foundation who would go on to designate
it SCP
1633 SCP 1633 is an anomalous computer
game created by a now defunct
independent game Studio the copy
currently being held by the foundation
is believed to be a beta version of the
game while the core gameplay is
relatively complete there are numerous
missing assets the music is largely
either missing or placeholder music and
the game is plagued by a large number of
graphical glitches because of the
generally buggy and glitchy nature of
the game the foundation considered both
Todd Howard and CD project red to be
major people and groups of interest in
the case however the discovery of other
key suspects eventually absolved them of
Suspicion for now this version of the
game was compiled 2 days before the
foundation raided the office of the
studio and is therefore believed to be
the most complete version of the game in
existence to be more specific about the
actual nature of the game itself SCP
1633 is a squad-based RPG with a
third-person camera perspective the
action is seen from an elevated
perspective with all characters on
screen aesthetically the game world is
steampunk and features various fantasy
creatures as enemies including including
elves dwarves Orcs goblins Etc fitting
with the steampunk style the game's
urban areas are modeled after Victorian
era London the four-player characters
are a band of Outlaws hired by the
Sinister Arch Duke of bodri to
investigate a theft however as the game
progresses it becomes a battle to save
the entire world as an ancient all
powerful being known as Kar intends to
wake from its thousand year Slumber and
Destroy Humanity the player controls a
squad of four characters with direct
control over one character at a time and
a command menu to control the other
three It is believed that in the game's
finish State a multiplayer option that
would have allowed four different real
world players to cooperate is likely to
have been included like many squad-based
games each character has a different
specialty The Marksman uses longrange
weapons The Alchemist has access to
potions and chemicals with various
effects the Rog can move stealthily and
assassinate enemies and the thug has
greater Health than the other characters
and does more melee damage and as is
also typical for games of this variety
XP earned from completing challenges and
killing enemies throughout the game
allows for players to upgrade the
abilities and stats of their characters
while the story and core gameplay
mechanics are nothing special there is
one element that pushes SCP 1633 into
anomalous territory and it's also the
element that would have been frontend
Center in The Finnish games marketing
campaign it's quote tactical heuristic
algorithm
these work in a unique fashion whenever
a player finishes a session and saves
their game the game will begin running
lengthy background processes when these
processes are complete a ptd or player
tactical data file is saved on the
computer when the save file and by
extension the associated ptd file is
loaded the enemies and challenges in the
game will have become far more effective
tailoring their methods to the
particular skills and tactics of the
player the extent to which this happen
happened is proportional to the amount
of time spent playing the game this kind
of Technology may seem theoretically
possible but the extent to which the
game pushes it causes it to rest in
anomalous territory the game's
programming is so intelligent that it
can tell simply by the tiniest clues in
your play style if you're loading a file
that isn't your own it will then pause
the game and make you load your own save
file and the tactics employed by the
enemies in the game as they learn more
about the player are nothing short short
of frightening at first the enemies will
adapt to the players's preferred weapons
strategies and overall play style then
they will realize that the player
character is controlled by an external
Force meaning of course you and begin to
mount psychological attacks directly on
the player through numerous tests the
foundation has been able to build a kind
of framework for the average player
experience through this framework we're
able to track and correlate average play
time with the average adaptability of
SCP 1633 to the player it is worth
noting that these effects do not apply
if the game is completed in a single
continuous playthrough for the purposes
of this experiment the game was stopped
saved and restarted at regular intervals
allowing the game to collect player
tactical data during the first 2 hours
the game's AI is abysmal with enemies
simply charging at the players with no
strategy whatsoever and typically being
mowed down however from 2 to 5 hours the
enemies undergo intelligence growth
adapting their play style to the types
of weapons they carry and their
environments at this stage this combat
level is also about equal to an
untrained human civilian from 5 to 8
hours enemies become considerably more
proficient and then begin countering the
player on their specific play Styles and
techniques for example they will attack
a player who uses long-range Weaponry
from cover with grenades or Splash
damage weapons to force them out into
the open they will also fully utilize
their environment for both defensive and
offensive purposes laying traps and
creating ambushes to surprise and kill
players at this point their combat
skills are equal to train soldiers from
8 to 12 hours the focus of the enemy
shifts from attacking the player
character to attacking the player
directly they engage in behaviors that
from an online playing perspective would
be considered griefing such as
intentionally blocking the player's view
or movement within the game enemies have
also been known to exploit player
expectations pretending to be broken or
glitched to make the player let their
guard down and then killing them in one
play session the enemies begin throwing
day flash spells similar to real life
flashbang grenades at the player they
throw them in a manner that created a
strobing effect causing the player to
have a grand M seizure Beyond 12 hours
the enemies engage in advanced
psychological tactics against the player
with methods that range wildly and tend
to be be specific to the player's
mindset and play style for example one
player likes to exert a high level of
control over all four of their squad
members in response enemies used attacks
that did little or no damage but caused
the characters to become dazed a state
which temporarily disrupts player
control however rather than attack the
dazed characters enemies simply surround
them in a crowd continually using days
attacks to prevent the player from doing
anything this caused major frustration
for the player and enemies may also
attempt to induce psychological Terror
among the players in one example enemies
somehow kidnapped one of the four player
characters and dragged them off screen
when this character was later found they
were strapped to a kind of sacrificial
altar this caused considerable anxiety
for the player it seems that this is the
upper limit of the game's anomalous
powers in most cases meaning things
typically level off after 12 hours
unless a specific entity appears to be
inhabiting the game which you'll learn
more about later in order to discover
the prior information the SCP Foundation
performed a series of tests on the game
with various different subjects in test
001 Junior researcher Ross an
experienced gamer who was pivotal in
first discovering the anomaly skipped
ahead of the typical preliminary d-class
tests seeing as he was already eager for
the game's nonanomalous release he was
also eager to be the first in line to
try it out on the foundation's dime
being a gamer Ross also found a number
of glitches and exploits in the game to
improve his performance allowing him to
run rings around his enemies however as
expected the enemies adapted to Ross's
techniques after Gathering his player
tactical data first they just began
using their weapons and exploiting the
environments more effectively but they
didn't stop there soon they became aware
of the same exploits Ross was using
before exploiting them themselves and
using it to beat him repeatedly in the
end they moved to the psychological
stage forcing Ross into a glitch that
rendered him unable to move he tried to
free his character for several minutes
until realizing he couldn't and rage
quit the game in test 002 they used a
d-class designated D
22930 he was a man with proven anger
issues even down to murdering his prior
girlfriend in a jealous rage initially
he enjoyed the game choosing the thug
character type and taking out his
aggression on the many enemies however
as went on the enemies became wise to
his tactic and began their psychological
attacks they gathered around the DCL
class's player character dropping their
weapons but the Swarm became so tightly
packed around the character that he
couldn't even move this started to cause
major frustration when the character
attempted to charge through the enemies
attacked killing him with their bare
hands in test 014 the foundation brought
in an agent with special forces
experiences with Advanced knowledge in
TCT iCal combat however even she was
worn down and defeated over time as the
enemies adapted to and exploited her
tactics the foundation even considered
using SCP 1633 as a tool for developing
effective countertactics in their real
life operations in test 021 the
foundation used a d-class with vast
experience in the world of commercial
gaming he was told to complete the game
in one playthrough taking pauses rather
than proper breaks as predicted with no
time to run the background processes and
create player tactical data files the
enemies weren't able to improve and the
d-class was able to complete the game in
around 13 hours however the game did
create a player tactical data file in
the aftermath of this playthrough and
used it to offer a new game plus mode to
the d-class when he began to play this
new game the screen displayed a
seemingly random pattern of black and
white pixels visually similar to
television static this image appeared to
be Neo hazardous as it caused Catatonia
and later death for the player and what
felt like a decidedly Petty move for SCP
1633 as alluded to earlier the game was
first discovered by Junior researcher
Ross who was an avid follower of the
independent game Studio initially
producing the game however while
frequenting developer fan forums he
found that various members of the team
were quitting the project for seemingly
bizarre reasons well this wasn't enough
on its own for the foundation to
intervene it was what first attracted
official attention they moved in after
the death of Gregor Tilman a game tester
for the company who died not long after
joining the project the foundation moved
in and after that gained control
shutting down the studio and taking
everything they had all anomalous
elements were isolated secured and
contained any loose ends were given
amnestics and recorded data on the
anomalous artifacts were destroyed it's
believed that one classified female
member of the dev team was behind the
the anomalous nature of the game but she
was able to escape and has since
attempted to join other development
teams she is now considered an active
person of interest and is being pursued
by mobile task force mw6 AKA don't hate
the player some final disturbing details
are recorded in a note left by the game
tester Gregor Tilman the note seized by
the foundation and included in SCP 1633
official file reads as follows I'm
writing this on paper cuz I don't think
he can learn it he got everything
digital real quick but I've unplugged
the router and broke my phone so I think
he's trapped in here but he won't stop
talking talking talking all the time at
the start of this job they told me all
about the Tactical algorithm stuff but
man I've been playing games all my life
and I knew I could beat it I I knew I
could handle this when I started playing
the game they learned quickly they kept
using the sniper rifle and after like an
hour they learned how to use cover then
another couple hours they'd set ambushes
then another hour and they started
sniping back while having a different
Squad flank me after that they figured
out how to glitch the physics engine and
ride crates at me or duck under the
floor they were learning but all that
was just easy stuff it was Evolution man
one bit figures something out so it
survives longer than the others it
wasn't directed after act three kraar
shows up he's supposed to be like this
Lovecraft Cosmic horror Crazy Monster
who can read the players's mind and
corrupt your soul he showed up right
after I killed strict the blood Drinker
that big spider monster supposed to have
this long speech about how I killed his
General on this plane and now he needs
to intervene directly or something but
instead he talked about how I was a
worthy adversary but I was cheating
because I was on another plane cnar
wasn't like the other enemies because he
wasn't supposed to be he was supposed to
be smart he was supposed to know
everything so he did he'd been watching
his minions fight me the whole time and
he knew everything they did it wasn't
just random mutations anymore it was
planned it wasn't Evolution man it was
actual intelligent design I brought it
home I had to know more I'm sorry but I
had to I copied the latest compile and
installed it on my home box and brought
my save game and that other file with me
on a flash drive it was the same there
he kept talking to me about how I was
keeping him from fulfilling his purpose
by keeping him trapped in a glass jar no
matter where I went in the game he kept
shouting and ranting then he did more at
first it was just slowing down in my
other programs the drive chugging when
it shouldn't be then the next time I
played the game he started talking about
my screen plays all the enemies look
like me I guess he could see through the
webcam he started needling me about
Jenny reading me bits of her emails
acting out the breakup he found the
videos of her and started making the
enemies talk in her voice then he was
everywhere in my computer I uninstalled
the game but he was still there he kept
opening documents and typing to me
calling me a foul cheat and a lowly worm
telling me to fight him on the same
plane as soon as I realized he was
outside the game I shut down my router
pulled out the network card but I don't
know if I got them quickly L enough
maybe he got out I turned the computer
off but he kept turning it back on I
wanted to break it but I didn't know if
that would kill him maybe it wouldn't
maybe it would let him out I tried
leaving the house but it was like I
could still hear him I couldn't leave
him alone because he might get out or do
something else I can't sleep haven't
slept since he came out I've been here
for 3 days and I can't leave I can't
leave him he keeps telling me to release
him but I can't I want to kill him but I
don't know if I can I I can't think
anymore I have to kill kill kill him
before he does anything new he won't
stop talking and I can't keep thinking I
can't keep going I'm sorry I have to go
now I'm sorry I'm sorry after studying
the note carefully the foundation
conducted a thorow investigation for any
other manifestations of this cnar entity
no mentions of it were found on any of
the other devices in Tillman's apartment
nor did a web search on the subject turn
up any relevant results at this time it
is believed that the entity
whatever it was or whatever it was
attempting to do was destroyed along
with Tillman's computer which he
appeared to have taken apart smashed and
burned in a metal trash can whatever
tormented him during his last days on
Earth is gone now thankfully because the
foundation currently owns the only copy
of the game and the game's anomalous
effects are only evident to active
players SCP 1633 poses no risk of
containment breach and therefore it has
been given the object class safe
one copy of SCP 1633 is stored on a
standard DVD ROM in a secure storage
locker in sight 15 along with all
supporting documentation and ancillary
materials any playthroughs of the game
must be approved by project head Dr
burger and all of said playthroughs are
to be monitored closely and subject to
strict rules after all this is one game
that doesn't play fair scp096 the shy
guy woke up in an unfamiliar Amar room
without a thought in its head however
one thing quickly occurred to it this
was not its containment chamber no the
solid steel Cube that had kept it locked
up for decades now didn't have a front
desk or walls covered in strange
childlike murals or tiny party music
playing over old speakers wherever
scp096 had found itself it certainly
wasn't the place it had come to call
home if it could read it would
registered the words behind the front
desk painted onto the wall ban Ban's
kindergarten where Joy Comes Alive
little did 096 know something really did
come to life here at band band's
kindergarten but it definitely wasn't
Joy scp096 was typically used to a much
more confined space so presented with so
much strange Freedom its natural
instinct was to wander around whimpering
quietly to itself this place was was
certainly peculiar with multiple large
reinforced doors each one having a large
red button fixed to the wall above them
a strange green creature was painted on
the wall with an a fixed speech bubble
that read jumbo Josh says eat fruits and
vegetables if you want to be strong like
me though 096 paid no mind to such
things this place looked like an SCP
Foundation containment facility mixed
with an off-brand chuckecheese and some
tiny part of the shy guys dim and dismal
brain wanted to see more of it what
other Secrets could it hold the shy guy
pressed one of the big red buttons
causing the doors to open underneath it
there was a faint sound of childish
laughter somewhere down the distant Hall
how had it ever found its way into such
a strange place the deeper the shy guy
wandered the more strange murals it saw
on the wall there was one for a large
orange cartoon jellyfish with one
staring eye where the speech bubble read
Stinger Flynn said says having many arms
allows me to help a lot of people then a
squat blue gorilla likee creature with
sharp lower teeth had a speech bubble
that read Captain fiddles says ooga
booga boaa a white feminine catlike
creature had the speech bubble bolina
says kindness is free so sprinkle it
everywhere a misshapen pink bird
creature had the speech bubble Opa bird
says laughter is the best medicine so
make sure to SM smile and of course most
importantly of all presiding over the
creativity room was a mural of a
grinning red creature wearing a pair of
party hats on its head like horns his
speech bubble read band ban says sharing
is caring your pancreas is mine a
whiteboard not far from this mural had
the words run for your lives hastily
scrawled onto it to anyone but the shy
guy who had no point of reference this
was clearly not a normal kindergarten G
as the shy guy passed into the hallway
slowly lumbering along it suddenly felt
an intense Spike of burning pain right
through its forehead Rising like a fever
pitch the shyu subdued whimpers quickly
escalated into horrifying whales of
animalistic rage this could only mean
one thing somewhere something had made
the terrible mistake of gazing at the
shy guy's face in fact not 10 ft away
the unfortunate opela bird had made that
very mistake it typically peaked out
from behind one of the hallways pillars
to get a good look at any potential
Intruders or new prey wandering into its
midst but this time the beastly Bird's
curiosity had taken it from Predator to
prey itself though it wouldn't realize
this until it was already too late as
the mutant bird creature scattered back
into the cavernous Hall filled with
plastic trees and an underwhelming play
area the shy guy came Galloping after it
on all fours roaring with fear y y the
opela bird was shocked to see the
creature giving chase this doesn't make
sense I meant to chase you you're not
meant to chase me but things are rarely
fair when it comes to the shy guy
arguably one of the most dangerous
euklid class creatures ever kept in
Foundation containment the opala bird
flapped desperately towards the boarded
up escape hatch but the shy guy was so
much faster he grabbed hold of the bird
gripping it in its iron clutches and
began to stretch open its bottom jaw
with a blood curdling Roar we'll spare
you the details of what happened next
but suffice to say little more than a
handful of feathers were left after
finishing off the opala bird the shy guy
reverted from Rage back to pitiful
sadness this place was no better than
the SCP Foundation there were still
creatures here to look at its face and
drive it into a state of extreme
emotional distress it was horrible the
shy guy needed to find a way to hide
himself away again so he decided to tear
away the planks covering up the escape
hatch and L down the narrow Hall and
there the shy guy actually found
something to its liking two platforms
one on either side of the room with what
seemed to be a deep dark Chasm between
the two for most there was an electrical
lift system for carrying them between
the platforms but the shy guy had no
interest in the platforms he only sought
the darkness below where nobody could
see his face that would suit him just
fine the shy guy jumped over the
guardrail and plummeted down below into
the dark feeling the air against its
cold gray skin as it fell felt wonderful
it dared to think that it might even
find solace in this deep dark place but
as soon as he hid something solid some
kind of metal lift system alarms went
off and flashing red lights soon made
everything down there in the darkness
visible to be exposed like this while it
thought it was hidden was the dreaded
Shy Guy's worst nightmare little did he
know he would soon become the worst
nightmare of a number of other beasts as
the shy guy crawled off the metal
platform hoping that perhaps it could
find another place to hide down here its
hands and feet splashed into shallow
water had something sprung a leak down
here the shy guy began wandering the
half dark as the water of this flooded
sub basement area pulled around him it
had no idea that another creature was
already sneaking up behind it getting
ready to strike before 096 could even
react several whip-like orange tentacles
wrapped around its Limbs and began
delivering an antagonizing shock through
its body more tentacles came in soon
after wrapping around the Shy Guy's body
and face delivering shock After Shock
After Shock with its millions of tiny
venomous Stinger barbs for a second it
seemed like the surprise attack might
actually be able to subdue the monster
but little did the shy guys attacker the
Monstrous real Stinger Flynn know that
but attacking it was just another way to
activate its Infamous rage State the
second that Stinger Flynn relented even
just for a moment the shy guy grabbed
him by the tentacles and slammed him
into the watery floor again and again
and again until the grip of his
tentacles loosened around the Shy Guy's
body and he was defenseless with stinger
panicked and immobilized the shy guy
released the full force of his
Supernatural Fury striking the Demonic
jellyfish with his fists until what was
couldn't be distinguished from the water
it used to be floating in Stinger Flynn
had been completely annihilated the shy
guy once again temporarily returned to a
state of calm and wandered out of this
watery basement into a nearby hallway
where everything was bright and dry the
walls were painted in garish childlike
drawings of a jungle with janky looking
animals the shy guy paid no mind to any
of it all he wanted was to find
somewhere that he could actually be
alone and away from prying eyes of all
these freaks this dream was shortlived
because as soon as the shy guy found a
new room a wide open Auditorium filled
with inflatable jungle trees like a
crude play area he was being stalked yet
again a powerful muscular Predator with
veins stretching over its bulging
muscles and blue skin it knew that this
Intruder had already killed two of its
fellow Garden dwellers but this time it
would put this spindly pale Stranger in
its place the shy guy heard something
rumbling towards it from behind and
turned upon hearing the blood curdling
war cry of ugaa boaa it was the gorilla
like Captain fiddles with strands of
saliva hanging from his tusks he leaped
onto the Shy Guy and began pounding into
its hideous face with his huge blue
fists Captain fiddles would destroy the
shy guy pound him into the concrete
until he stopped moving the one thing
that Captain fiddles didn't expect was
for the shy guy to start fighting back
and he was about to learn the hard truth
that the shy guy could fight a lot
harder than him the scp's spindly but
immensely powerful arms grabbed Captain
fiddles by the shoulders and threw him
into the wall causing huge cracks to
crawl up towards the ceiling before
Captain fiddles could even think about
wrenching himself free the shy guy
leaped to his feet and bounded over to
him the shy guy grabbed Captain fiddles
by the ankles and ripped him out of the
wall letting his body drop to the floor
and then unleashing hell upon him
Captain fiddles would have begged for
mercy if he wasn't already dead before
the shy guy could even begin to calm
down a trap door opened in the floor
beneath him dropping him into a new area
a multicolored maze where 096 was
trapped like a helpless rat with the
body count of an atomic bomb once again
the shy guy didn't need to go looking
for trouble because trouble was already
on its way the pure white catlike ban
bolina pounced from a sharp corner in
the maze claws bared she jumped onto the
shy guy latching onto him inclin trying
to scratch his nightmare of a face if
the shy guy had ever possessed anything
resembling patience he would have run
out long before now he grabbed bambolina
shrugging off the pain of her claws and
tossing her into the darkness high above
she flew off with a catlike yell and hit
some distant ceiling with a crunch
suffice to say she wouldn't be back to
bother the shy guy again tired and angry
the pale mination didn't feel like
wandering through a maze instead it just
charged straight through destroying
colorful wall after colorful wall when
it encountered whatever was behind this
extremely frustrating afternoon it would
destroy it with extreme prejudice that
was almost certainty after breaking
through one more wall the shy guy
tumbled out into a strange room where a
grinning red creature was waiting for
him wearing two party hats on top of his
head this was no mere Lackey it was ban
ban himself the one behind this
nightmarish kindergarten he stared right
into the shy guy's face with no fear at
all almost like he knew something that
the shy guy didn't and it was true he
had no plan to fight the shy guy himself
he'd brought a champion with him as the
shy guy started to scream and rage all
the boxes behind ban ban tumbled out of
the way as a huge figure Rose a behemoth
at least 50 ft tall with green skin
giant teeth and huge staring eyes it was
jumbo Josh and if the shy guy wanted to
graduate from this nightmare
kindergarten it would need to defeat him
and ban ban the shy guy growled digging
its claws into the ground and preparing
to charge forward challenge accepted you
all know exactly who I am the bald
chemistry teacher looked around at the
men surrounding him in the desert
Cadillacs leather jackets blacked out
Shades the gang members shifted
nervously from foot to foot as the man
bragged openly about what he's done to
build his criminal Empire Walter White's
attention turned back to the men in
front of him a slight sneer played
around his lips now say my name the man
took a moment to reply as the desert
wind blew behind him he seemed to be
weighing his options realizing quickly
that he had lost all control over the
situation you're you're Heisenberg
you're G bang Walter White fell to the
ground dead the characters all around
yeled in Surprise Drew their guns and
started wildly pointing them around the
circle trying to figure out who killed
the great Heisenberg but his killer just
stared in awe from his couch in the
front room as the Netflix show kept
playing on the TV had the toy gun in his
hand really done that Josh had admitted
to himself that he had a problem a long
time ago but at least being a yard sale
addict was cheaper than just a regular
old retail addict addict actually in
truth he was also an estate sale addict
a garage sale addict and a thrift store
addict anywhere you could buy people's
old junk for rock bottom prices he would
sniff it out the Saturday that his life
changed forever was just like any other
Saturday really in the sweaty heat of
the Atlantic City suburbs he hadn't
meant to stop by any sales today but one
just so happened to catch his eye there
was a box marked nerd stuff and he took
that as a personal challenge was this
some old lady's version of nerd stuff or
a veteran dungeon Master's Treasure
Trove the reality was somewhere in
between the two there were a couple of
seasons of Buffy on VHS a copy of the
original deos X and some Legend of Zelda
plushies it hadn't really been worth
stopping his car for except for a little
plastic splash of color that caught his
eye Josh reached way down to the bottom
of the box and rooted around for it
there was no way it couldn't possibly be
the toy he'd spent all his childhood
after asking for and never getting but
in fact it was a 1985 Nintendo
Entertainment System zapper with an
orange grip and Barrel NES gray Bodywork
and the Beautiful font printed along the
side it was unmistakable he threw a wad
of cash at the old lady behind the table
and rushed back into his car quickly as
he could it was time to cancel his Day
plans he had a childhood dream to
fulfill but no sooner that he had got
home and flipped on his TV the Dream
came crashing down around him his old
NES the one he'd had since he was a
little kid had sadly keeled over it
refused to power on no matter what he
did so that made his zapper pretty much
useless the best he could do with it now
would be to point it at the TV and make
pew pew noises with his mouth so Josh
opened up Netflix and put on an episode
of Breaking Bad little did he know as he
raised the zapper to the screen that he
was actually in possession session of
SCP
674 nobody would know looking at it on
the surface even the most hardcore
Gamers wouldn't have a clue because you
can fully disassemble clean and
reassemble the zapper and get no
indication that it's anything other than
what it appears to be however as soon as
the gun is pointed at a television
screen or a computer monitor of any kind
it starts to pose a very real threat or
at least a very real fictional threat if
you shoot at the screen whatever media
is playing on it at the time will react
and adapt to what has just happened that
means characters on the screens will
react in accordance with the rules of
their respective universes in a grounded
realistic drama The Gunshot will behave
like any other killing or wounding the
victim with perhaps enough time for them
to give a dying monologue but in an
episode of Rick and Morty the shock
could manifest in any number of bizarre
and creative ways news crews that
witness the user shooting a person in
their live report will continue to cover
the incident as if it is part of the
ongoing story if you shoot Walter White
he falls to the ground dead Josh stared
at the screen in utter amazement he
didn't expect the writers to kill off
their main character just like that
wasn't there supposed to be another Nine
episodes what would they do to fill all
that time as the episode played out it
seemed to mostly just follow Jesse
trying desperately to escape with his
money before it was too late he kept
glancing towards the camera for some
reason with a slide look of fear in his
eyes very strange creative decision
there Josh backed out of the show to
scroll through his continue watching
there was something a little creepy
about how he pointed the zapper at the
TV pulled the trigger and perfectly at
that moment a character had been shot
time to pick out another show without
any guns and murder for a bit you know
something safe The Familiar meloda tune
filled the lounge as various shots of
Dunder Mifflin employees busied
themselves shredding credit cards and
answering phone calls it never ceased to
make his worries go away seeing the
words the office appear on the screen he
settled into the couch watching as the
characters all gathered in the
conference room for some first aid
training the CPR dummy lay on the floor
with Michael Scott earnestly explaining
to the woman that the victim appeared to
have lost their limbs he laughed along
as the scene descended into chaos as
none of the employees took the training
seriously at all even though he'd seen
this episode countless times it never
got old absent-mindedly he pointed the
gun at the TV and pulled the trigger
bang Pam collapsed on the ground all of
the characters Dove out of the way
trying to find cover behind their chairs
not daring to peek out at the camera
only the first aid lady stayed on the
scene trying her best to resuscitate Pam
it cut to a shot of Dwight talking to
the camera sadly he said that it was
almost funny but there was a real
heaviness in the moment his eyes were
red like he'd been crying off camera
Josh flipped the TV off and stared at
himself in the dark reflection was he
dreaming he hadn't just done that had he
fortunately for Josh and for the rest of
humanity he had not killed Jenna friser
or Brian Cranston he hadn't even killed
their characters in the shows at least
not for anyone other than himself
Research into SCP 674 shows that the
appearance of characters being killed
off on screen only exists in the mind of
the shooter for everyone else the office
Remains the Same as it always was
unfortunately for Josh however Pam is
now dead in that universe and will
always be whenever he watches an episode
it leaves a real Shadow over the later
Seasons but the characters apparently
managed to do a good job pivoting into
its new darker tone other shows that
have been tested and research conditions
have yielded interesting results like in
Star Trek it is impossible to actually
kill Captain Kirk instead various red
shirts always just so happen to dive in
front of him or fall into frame at the
pivotal moment with a small Dead Zone on
the right hand side of the screen
characters who witness enough shootings
have the sense to stick to that side of
the frame whenever the shot is on them
sometimes going so far as to plead
directly with a viewer breaking the
fourth wall in their desperation to
survive when Josh came back from a long
walk outside he'd convinced himself that
what he had seen earlier was all just
some vivid dream a dream he didn't
remember waking up from but definitely
wasn't happening anymore he'd play some
video games that's what he would do he
had decided he would just play some
Super Smash Bros and unwind anyone who
has ever said that sentence to
themselves will know firsthand how
foolish that is not 10 minutes later
Josh had definitely forgotten all about
his dream from before he was too busy
raging and cursing at the screen he
couldn't stand playing against King
dididi that stupid Hammer move always
got him without thinking Josh snatched
the zapper from the couch next to him
and blasted Didi right in the face in
classic Smash Bros style the giant
penguin King was launched backwards
flying off the screen in a blast of
colorful smoke but he didn't respond for
a second his character just stood on the
screen awkwardly before it kicked him
back out to the character's select
screen this time though King Didi's
picture was missing Josh couldn't help
himself he set up a free-for-all match
straight away picking all the characters
he hated to fight against Sonic Mario
Pikachu Bowser link NES even fit trainer
one after the other bang bang bang he
felt a strange sense of satisfaction
once he'd done his work great now the
character list only had the fair
balanced ones left they just so happened
to all be his favorite characters too
but why stop there Josh jumped across to
Elden ring and marched his night up
through the gate to Stormville Castle
before marget even had gotten through
his opening cutscene Josh had shot the
boss right in the face this boss battle
that he he' been stuck on for hours was
over before it even started what could
he do now he put on an episode of
stranger things and shot the demogorgan
then moff Gideon in the Mandalorian and
some goblins in Hogwarts Legacy the
clickers from The Last of Us took a
couple extra shots but went down easy
enough he went over to his PC and killed
the Ender Dragon in Minecraft without
blowing up any beds he won a game of
Rocket League 530 after he shot both
cars on the opposing team he played
through doors in Roblox without a single
jump scare he would just shoot any
monster that filled his screen what
could be better he reckoned it was time
for more movies walking back across the
lounge spinning the gun around his
finger like a western he wondered if now
would be a good chance to hunt down all
the legendary animals in Red Dead 2 it
would certainly make the job a lot
easier if he could kill them all in just
one shot he just need to be careful not
to shoot Arthur by accident but then
Josh sat on the remote the TV flicked
over to an old rerun of Bob Ross just
that he'd been squaring up to shoot he
pulled the trigger before he could react
the canvas was splattered red from
somewhere off camera he heard the
artist's wheezing voice try to comfort
him there are no mistakes
just happy but he died before he could
say another word the exposition gun
first came onto the SCP foundation's
radar when a strange police report was
doing the rounds on an email chain
amongst local authorities they were all
finding a great deal of value from a man
called Josh who had turned himself in at
his local station in Atlantic City for
quote killing like everyone naturally
the police took his report very
seriously for all of about 10 minutes as
soon as they realized he was talking
about video games TV and movie
characters the whole case turned into
one big joke they sat Josh down in front
of a TV and played him episodes of the
shows he was talking about pointing out
characters still alive in scenes after
he'd supposedly shot them them to death
but he seemed to just grow more
distressed as he realized he was
experiencing this phenomenon Alone by
the time Foundation agents tracked Josh
down and took him in for questioning the
gun had moved on he marched it straight
back to the old lady who' sold it to him
who had then sold it on again Josh's
full account of events and description
of the zapper were taken before he was
administered Class C amnestics and
allowed to continue with his yard sale
addiction uninhibited SCP 67 4 was found
sometime later in the possession of a
33-year-old Caucasian male simply
referred to as Mr S A reclusive man in a
neighboring City Mr s first gained the
SCP foundation's attention through his
extremist political blog in which he
claimed to have assassinated prominent
political figures news anchors and talk
show hosts while the truth of those
claims was demonstrably false it was
clear from the way he described events
that he really did believe the delusion
after being questioned it was discovered
that he had never left his home instead
he stayed on his couch watching news
reports and firing at any prominent
figures that appeared believing that he
was indeed killing them in the real
world despite claiming that he was using
SCP 674 to prevent a military police
state using the device to assassinate so
many high-profile figures had the
opposite effect on his video reality in
his blog posts he described an
increasingly unstable Global Order
martial law and catastroph Ric events
consistent with the hypothetical release
of two deadly scps his house was
barricaded with security cameras set up
in every direction the more he had been
using the gun the more the characters
and journalists on TV had threatened him
claiming that the SCP Foundation were on
their way to apprehend him and that he
would face retribution for what he had
been doing Mr s's intended ambush of
foundation agents failed while they
appeared to be dying on the security
feeds he had set up the agent
experienced no physical harm in reality
as they apprehended the man and seized
SC SCP 674 while the majority of
researchers have deemed that SCP 674 is
harmless to all but the mental
well-being of the shooter there was a
notably Sinister result to Mr s's time
in Foundation detention alone in his
cell Mr s soon started to engage in
heated arguments with the security
camera set up to monitor him there is no
record of any voices in the room other
than his own yet seemed to be locked in
a fierce argument all of a sudden Mr s
dropped to the ground Dead with three 38
caliber handgun bullets lodged in his
chest the entirety of his holding cell
was searched for evidence of a shooter
but none was found the exposition gun
remains in a locked plastic case in
storage site 23 aside from regular
cleaning and maintenance it is used
under controlled circumstances to
creatively gather intelligence about
further SCP activity in the event of the
site being compromised Personnel are
allowed to destroy the exposition gun at
their own discretion should it fall into
the wrong hands rock paper scissors a
simple hand game dating back to the Han
Dynasty of Imperial China it is a
decisive game between two players with
the only outcomes being Win Lose or Draw
we're quite familiar with rock paper
scissors here at the SCP Foundation as
the guards are often seen playing
intense rounds of the game to determine
who will be the Unlucky Soul chosen to
secure one of the various ker class scps
during a given week in most cases this
use of rock paper scissors is accepted
as a largely harmless and Fair Way for
defensive Personnel to arrange their
shifts the reason for this is that the
results of rock paper scissors are
generally random as there are very few
ways for an individual's skill to
influence the game or so one might think
in reality rock paper scissors is a
deeply psychologic local game and this
is mainly because of its origin as a
contest between fellow human beings the
average human is vulnerable to making
errors and falling into patterns and
with only three options to keep track of
it is entirely possible for a season
veteran of rock paper scissors to
predict their opponent's Choice before
any hands are thrown of course that
opponent may also commit an error of
their own by misreading the other
players's actions and thus there is
always a chance for an impulsive
decision to swing the results of the
game in either direction human
limitation is the only skill-based
mechanic in the game of rock paper
scissors and that same limitation is
what in the eyes of some holds the game
back from reaching its true potential
that was the case until someone out
there discovered the rules to an
anomalous version of rock paper scissors
being spread through a mysterious email
while all attempts to trace the email
back to its original sender have left
the foundation with more questions than
answers we have been been able to learn
more about the differences between the
rules of standard rock paper scissors
and the anomalous version we have given
this anomalous version of rock paper
scissors the designation SCP
4633 and unlike the classic edition
under no circumstances are any
foundation Personnel allowed to play a
game incorporating any of the
alternative rules while the ceiling for
skill and variety is theoretically much
higher in a rock paper scissors match
featuring SCP
4633 the risks to the player far
outweigh any added novelty here is how
SCP 4633 functions during an average
game of rock paper scissors well average
prior to the anomalous properties taking
effect rather than being limited to
using merely rock paper or scissors as
the name of the game implies the players
gain access to a series of additional
hand gestures which upon the act of
being thrown become seamlessly
integrated into both players shared
understanding of the rules this this
alone would be bizarre enough but the
true harm caused by a CP 4633 is in the
nature of the gestures themselves when
one of the non-standard gestures Allowed
by SC SCP 4633 is used the player's
hands will change shape in ways that
under normal circumstances would be
anatomically impossible each of these
non-standard gestures is distinct from
the rest with the only commonality being
an unusual tendency for the final
gesture to resemble biological
structures often seen in sea life one
particular gesture might cause a player
to rapidly grow a ring of additional
fingers surrounding a gaping anemone
like mouth in the Palm while another
could result in the player's entire arm
flattening into a fin-like appendage
regardless of how severe a departure
from a typical human limb the final
gesture would be the limbs and on rare
occasions the entire body of the player
using the gesture will quickly and
irreversibly mutate into the shape
requiring to successfully perform it
while these gestures overwhelmingly
result in forms that would be
distressing to most people the same
cognitive effect that causes the
participants to accept changes to the
rules also appears to apply to the
changes affecting their own bodies to
the players of an SCP 4633 augmented
match of rock paper scissors the
non-standard gestures seem as mundane as
the original Three unfortunately the
morphic properties of SCP 4633 are
practically IR reversible with extreme
reconstructive surgery being required in
even the best of cases in all instances
of SCP
4633 surgical intervention is necessary
to prevent the spread of details
regarding the non-standard gestures and
their usage because of the immediate
shift in cognitive awareness among
participants all that is needed for a
new instance of SCP 4633 to occur is the
faintest hint of knowledge of the
alternative rules it's even been noted
that between different groups of players
the non-standard gestures can vary
heavily or seemingly be created on the
fly as the desire to win at all costs
takes hold here are a few examples of
anomalous gestures which have been
observed during instances of SCP
4633 this list is by no means
comprehensive but it will provide an
insight into how SCP 4633 drastically
Alters the existing mechanics of the
game as well as the physique of the
players the Thor gesture transforms the
user's fingers into Barb tentacles it
beats paper and scissors but loses to
rock Chava folds the fingers of the hand
into the palm and causes them to emerge
through the back of the Palm it allows
the user to throw a second gesture after
they've seen their opponent's Choice
ashaz splits the hand into a pair of
poisonous Stingers which also produce a
potent electrical current between them
it has been seen to lose to paper but
seemingly of their own will The Stingers
lashed at the the opposing player and
cause them to fall unconscious three
rounds later due to the effects of the
poison shaa beats paper and two other
anomalous gestures loses to scissors
rock and a third gesture and morphs the
user's arm into a dactal club similar to
the front appendage of a mantis shrimp
is zerov simply causes the player to
grow three additional thumbs on one hand
the final gesture resembles a triple
thumbs up is zorov has not been seen to
beat any gestures and the player who
uses it always seems to go on to lose
the match pakar causes the middle and
ring to recede into the hand while the
pointer and pinky fingers extend to
resemble the ice stalks of a snail or
slug the rest of the hand also becomes
coated in a thin layer of slime which
continues to secrete from within pakar
beats scissors and paper but loses to
rock in another anomalous gesture known
as vianek incidentally Von causes the
arm of the player using it to elongate
into a wormlike tube that periodically
spews a gout of saltwater on the
opponent when vianek was seen beating
pakmar the saltwater appeared to have
some adverse effect on the latter
gesture causing the I stocks to droop
and the hand to shrivel until it was
half its original size another anomalous
gesture is gatho recognized by the skin
muscle and veins of the hand turning
translucent revealing a pulsing red
organ in the interior of the Palm once
gathr has been thrown the player who
used it may call out the name of one
other gesture which can no longer be
used in the current match the ukay
gesture is a bit deceptive as it
resembles Rock when first thrown but
gradually causes the hand to condense
into a lump of inert material not
dissimilar to actual ous rock the
knuckles as well begin to exude a
superheated mineral substance similar to
molten lava ukay exclusively beats paper
and appears to lose to everything else
many of the gestures on record have no
known name but they function within SCP
4633 is altered rules is clear from the
context in which they were used such is
the case with one anomalous gesture
which caused most of the players hand to
withdraw into a siphon likee opening at
their wrist before the very same orifice
shot out a stream of ink into the
opposing player's eyes while there was
no lasting harm done to the opponent by
this gesture the ink did cause temporary
blindness which persisted until they
were defeated by way of their Rock
losing to paper another unknown gesture
has been seen beating both urav and ukog
this gesture makes the player's hand
resemble the crest and gas filled body
of a Pacific Mana War these examples are
only scraping the surface of the
seemingly Endless Possibilities that SCP
4633 has to offer as you can see the
anomalous hand gestures can be just as
dangerous within the game itself as the
permanent changes they invoke in the
user while the foundation has done its
best to contain all information
surrounding SCP 4633 there have been
clear efforts by several unknown groups
to push the game into continued usage
over the past 3 decades instances of SCP
4633 have seen increasing popularity in
the world of highstakes gambling Perhaps
it is because of the inherent thrill of
watching two opponents trying to
strategically outwit each other with a
countless number of non-standard
gestures but more likely it is part of
the anomalous effect of SCP 4633 that
the game would appeal to the those
desperate to risk everything on the slim
chance of Victory this neatly brings us
to the SCP 4633 related incident which
occurred aboard the private ocean liner
known as the SS fateful Emma before the
incident the Fateful Emma would sail
into international waters twice a year
each time it would bring along a new
group of passengers seemingly selected
from the underprivileged and downcast
sector of society a great many of these
passengers were convicts with repeat
violent offenses chosen en from supermax
facilities the world over the process by
which these inmates were chosen for a
voyage aboard the ship was not
dissimilar from the methods the
foundation uses to acquire new class D
Personnel naturally this was how the
research team was able to be tipped off
about the Fateful Emma it became
apparent soon after looking into the
ship's career that the individuals
altered by the effects of SCP 4633 had
been seen departing from the ship on
multiple occasions in remote island
Harbors most of the time the individuals
would also be to the best of their
ability with their metamorphosed forms
carrying briefcases filled with hundreds
of thousands of dollars in cash while
Witnesses tend to write off the strange
appearances of those affected as being
the result of a deformity or injury or
in more pronounced instances dismissing
the encounters as sightings of creatures
from the local mythology it was clear to
anyone familiar with as CP 4633 what was
truly going on these passengers were
being made to play Pitch games of rock
paper scissors featuring SCP
4633 for massive sums of wealth and what
was worse the Grand Prize winners were
seemingly being released back into
civilization without the knowledge of
law enforcement of course what the
foundation was most concerned about was
the potential for the large scale leak
of detailed information involving SCP
4633 it seemed that the foundation's
latest faceless enemy had revealed
itself whatever wealthy group of
individual ual was pulling the strings
behind the games aboard the SS fateful
Emma it was very likely that the ship
was also well protected by a private
Army of trained mercenaries in a display
of Swift but necessary initiative the
foundation assembled a brand new mobile
task force to be dispatched onto the
ocean liner mobile task force row 52
with the fitting code name r Shambo the
mobile task force would board The Vessel
secretly and use whatever means
necessary to prevent the spread of SCP
463 3 3 and any evidence of the
associated non-standard hand gestures
before the Fateful Emma's next Voyage
the foundation isolated the port where
it would depart from and made sure that
the MTF agents were in position the
operation was co- captained by agent
duah and agent Shang both of whom prided
themselves on having extraordinarily
good luck agent duah would stealthily
move the majority of the agents under
his command into the cargo hold below
deck and await agent jang's signal agent
Jang himself would assume the name and
identity of one of the criminal
passengers who was intercepted before
boarding by the mobile task force the
wouldbe participant was subsequently
detained and brought into the foundation
as a Class D personnel as the SS fateful
Emma began to leave the harbor agent
Jang joined the other passengers who had
been gathered together in an enormous
function hall there was little
indication of when the games would begin
and Jang made an effort to keep a low
profile until more information was
available shortly after after the ship
had officially arrived in international
waters an eccentric man entered the room
on a walkway that overlooked the rest of
the passengers he was flanked by a pair
of armed bodyguards it was plain from
the man's style of dress and demeanor
that he was both absurdly wealthy and
completely out of his mind he wore a
pure white tuxedo and a scarf that
seemed to have been made from the fur of
a Siberian tiger a pair of Dark Shades
with sequin rims obscured his eyes from
view but by far the strangest aspect of
the rich man was the fact that emerging
from the wrist of his right arm was the
eyeless head of a mo eel where his hand
should be the man spoke addressing the
entire room welcome passengers new and
old to the SS fateful Emma while you
aboard this ship your fate is in your
own hands over the next 24 hours you
will have the rare opportunity to play
the greatest game of chance that
Humanity has ever known generations of
people from every continent and everywh
Walk of Life have given their all to the
Mastery of rock paper scissors across
no the men proceeded to speak unusual
syllables for the next minute straight
without even a pause for breath in his
report agent Jen described the man's
voice as gaining an increasingly loud
hum as his speech continued and that
some of the syllables didn't seem to be
the product of human vocal cords he soon
concluded his string of gibberish and
resumed speaking intelligible language
as is custom AR we will be utilizing the
Iles toi rules you will Begin by
selecting a single opponent and
challenging them to a best of two of
three match this is a single elimination
tournament and any competitors who
cannot otherwise continue to engage in
matches will also be eliminated by the
end of your time here the luckiest among
you will be named the Undisputed
champion of these games and will be
granted unlimited Freedom along with the
cash prize the rest of you will have to
determine your own Fates for you all
know what awaits you below may your
hands be ready your minds be sharp and
remember winning is everything with a
flourish of his Mor eel hand the wealthy
man finished his introductions and
promptly exited the room aent Jang
looked at the passengers surrounding him
and saw that they were already beginning
to play Rock Paper Scissors with each
other a few had already begun using the
anomalous gestures warping their limbs
into hideous subnotica shapes agent Jen
gave the signal to agent duah and the
rest of the mobile task force to begin
the operation their target was primarily
the Moray handed man as well as any
other Close Associates that he had on
board they would capture him alive and
interrogate him into revealing the
mystery behind this illegal gambling
Reign once the mercenaries were dealt
with agent Dub's team would further
command the ocean liner and navigated to
SCP Foundation research site 45 to await
further orders as for agent Jang he knew
what he had to do to buy time he would
participate in the ensuing rock paper
scissors tournament and eliminate as
many of the other players as possible
this he believed was the best way to
minimize the number of anomalous
gestures that would be used aboard the
ship of course he himself wouldn't be
using any of the anomalous gestures
either opting to limit himself to the
standard three this could put him at a
severe disadvantage over the course of
the competition but aent Jang knew
better than to tempt fate still being
eliminated seemed like something he may
want to avoid even though the
consequences for elimination were left
vague in the strange rich man's speech
he still didn't feel that it would be
wise to put himself in a compromised
position while aboard the Fateful Emma
bracing himself for the worst agent Jang
accepted the challenge of a nearby
passenger he was off to a promising
start when he threw a scissors hand
against his opponent's paper because the
matches were best two out of three all
he needed was to win one of the next two
matches and he'd survive this round then
he saw the devious look on his
opponent's face and he knew that this
match was about to get weird rather than
admit defeat a and jien prepared to
throw scissors again the two challenged
their hands and just as jien had feared
his opponent threw an anomalous gesture
almost instantly the opponent's hand
took on a multim mouthed pene form which
began to spit sharp teeth in agent
jang's Direction fortunately the agent's
bulletproof vest was able to withstand
the impact of the teeth what was even
more fortunate was the fact that the
opponent seemed to be a good sport
scissors be TZ ROK you in said the other
passenger before walking away in search
of their next match curiously the
passenger's transformed arm continued to
fire teeth across the room at random
intervals occasionally hitting and
causing injury to one of the other
competitors agent Jang was grateful that
the body armor he was wearing had been
tested to withstand rapid fire from SCP
127 compared to the raw power of the
living gun the teeth launch from azrok
gestures were practically BB rounds he
had succeeded in not being eliminated
both from the game and generally excited
about his win Jang sought out another
opponent to test his luck below deck
agent duah and the rest of the mobile
task force had just finished facing off
against some of the hired mercenaries
when they entered a room presumed to be
the ocean liners Sick Bay inside was a
Grizzly sight a second rock paper
scissors tournament playing out between
players that had been so thoroughly
transformed by the anomalous gestures of
SCP
4633 that they barely appeared to still
be human was like a scene from a deep
sea documentary with strange and
unknowable creatures fying for dominance
not within a natural food chain or
competition for resources but within a
seemingly never-ending struggle to win a
game of chance it was Purgatory rock
paper scissors Purgatory agent duah was
appalled but he knew better than to
attempt to stop these creatures from
doing the one thing keeping them all
distracted the morh handed man was still
somewhere in the ship and capturing him
was far more important the research team
would decide what to do with these
former humans once the ship was Secure
within the foundation's custody however
what agent Duan didn't realize is that
some of these creatures were advancing
on his team in nightmarish and unearthly
voices they chanted rock rock paper
scissors suddenly one of the
Abominations who resembled nothing more
closely than an enormous mass of coral
produced Four Arms from within its body
and began to throw anomalous hands signs
towards the agents one of the arms threw
ayag which coated an unsuspecting agent
in hot lava causing him to drop to the
floor in pain Panic duah ordered the
task force to eliminate every living
thing in the Sick Bay although not in
the sense of their tournament standing
of course meanwhile aent Jang was on a
wi streak in the function hall through
sheer luck and determination he had
managed to avoid elimination while
eliminating several other passengers
himself he began to notice that those
who were eliminated were quietly
escorted Away by the bouncers seeming to
have their anomalous changes treated now
it was only down to 12 remaining
passengers agent Jen knew that it was
only a matter of time before Duba and
his team took control of the ship but
feeling Reckless he challenged one of
the remaining passengers in that moment
something came over him as if his
determination to the mission through was
also compelling him to win at any cost
his opponent threw pakar and out of
instinct Jen threw vyan the agent went
on to win the entire tournament but
sadly he was unable to collect the prize
money as during the Skirmish below deck
the man with a moay hand had escaped
with a small fortune in a high-speed
submersible his ultimate goals and the
scope of the shadowy group he
represented would remain unanswered for
the time being when the SS fateful Emma
finally arrived at sight 45 agent Jen
came to his senses and realized that he
had underestimated the cognitive side
effects of SCP
4633 due to the immediately recognizable
anomalous state of both his arms agent
Jen was later contained on site with
minimal security it's believed that
researchers are still searching for a
method to reverse the effects it just
goes to show that winning isn't
everything did you hear that not so long
ago a 5-year-old boy went up against 12
of Russia's greatest chess Grand Masters
and do you know what happened he lost
every single match that's because
winning a chess dear viewers isn't easy
chess is an ancient game of strategy
cunning and skill it's not just about
thinking one step ahead of your opponent
that's not going to be enough make a
wrong prediction and you could end up
sacrificing one of your pieces as well
as vital space on the board but thinking
two to three steps ahead beating your
adversaries moves before they even been
made now there's a viable strategy
tricky but viable after all if it was
easy we'd all be Queen Gambit level
chess prodigies Eric Matthews had never
been good at the game but he had a
pretty substantial reason to keep trying
and that reason's name was Brian
Matthews his father you see for as long
as Eric could remember his dad had
regarded a high level of skill on the
chessboard to be a sign of intellectual
superiority intelligence was something
that Brian put quite a considerable
value on given that he was a professor
at a university in their home country of
England some of Eric's earliest memories
were of playing chess with his dad
usually on a Friday night when Brian got
home after a week of giving lectures to
the next generation of Scholars
obviously with his son at such a young
age the professor would take it easy on
Eric playing in a much laxer fashion
focusing instead on teaching the boy the
basics of the game and for a time at
least it was good it was a rare time
that Eric and his academic father could
spend bonding after all with his mother
gone his dad was all he had but as the
years passed the game Changed by the
time Eric was a teenager Brian had
stopped pulling his punches on the
chessboard he hoped his son would build
on what he'd learned when they played in
the past using those skills to best his
dad on the board but to Eric playing
chess had never been about a purely
educational experience it was more about
spending time with his old man Time
After Time the young man's pawns fell
prey to Brian's expertly considered and
far more competitive moves try as he
might Eric couldn't best his dad he
tried his best and never stopped putting
the effort into every game but thinking
too hard about one possible plan of
attack left him wide open to a counter
strategy from the professor over and
over again he landed himself in
Checkmate or made illegal moves without
even realizing it it every time earning
criticism and chastisement from his
scholarly father every game it got worse
it was like Eric could feel his father's
gaze and the weighty expectations behind
it with each move he made across the
board there were so many nights where he
wondered if it would be better to give
up entirely to knock down his own King
and concede but how could he ever find
any other shared interests with his dad
beyond the two of them playing chess it
had become a Lifeline tethering father
and son together and to cut it now left
Eric uncertain if he'd sink or be able
to swim alongside Brian he had long
admired his father his achievements in
Academia were impossible to avoid with
more framed certificates hung up on the
walls than there were photos of the pair
of them together but the shadow had cast
over him made Eric desperate to keep
this one shred of Common Ground alive
Eric wasn't the type to give up despite
how much of an uphill struggle the
situation felt like taking a leaf out of
his profess her father's scholarly ways
he decided to learn the game inside and
out every known move and strategy he
would research the entire history of
Chess itself if that's what it took to
play with the same skill as his dear old
dad over the coming weeks Eric checked
out every book at his local library on
the subject beginner's guides Advanced
Rule books and even a few volumes on
notable players throughout the
extensively long history of the game
along the way a chapter of a certain
book stood out to Eric it described a
chess Prodigy from Russia who had
created an early mechanical chess device
known as the samurai it had been
designed to be a traveling curiosity and
would sit playing chess games against
volunteers taken from a spectating
audience each one of them having forked
over some of their hard-earned money to
watch this man-made wonder the Russian
chess Prodigy's young daughters also had
a love for the game seeing that gave
Eric a Pang of jealousy wondering if
those daughters had as much trouble
playing their own father as he did with
Brian but at least there was an
underlying shred of Hope there too if
this father and his daughters could bond
over chess maybe there was a chance for
Eric and his dad too sadly it's one
thing to try and learn all the facts you
can about Chess it's an entirely
different Beast to put all that
information to use and apply it to an
actual game despite having read every
book he could get his hands on Eric
still couldn't best Brian at the for it
was like nothing had changed his father
barely noticed when Eric tried to
replicate move sets he'd read up on and
still managed to not only counter those
moves but check his Queen in the process
so practice Eric thought after all
practice was supposedly meant to make
perfect right the plan was simple if he
practiced his chess moves enough times
and figure out how he could call on what
he'd learned then he might stand a
chance at winning when he and his dad
played each other there was just one
hiccup to this Plan Eric needed someone
to practice against the only other
person in the house was Brian meaning it
was that hiccup that turned into a
problem almost big enough to stop Eric
in his tracks that is until he went into
his father's lab it was under the house
itself a sort of su LEL maybe used as a
basement or seller by the previous
owners but since Professor Matthews and
his son had lived there the entire room
had been remodeled into an atome
laboratory not a terribly Advanced one
of course this was the early '90s after
all majority of Brian's time even when
he was at home instead of working at the
University was spent on his own
downstairs in the lab Eric had gone down
there in search of his dad to ask him if
there was anyone whom he knew who he
could practice and develop his chess
skills with but instead what he found
down there was the last thing he
expected to see not that he had any clue
exactly what it was at first the thing
was some kind of bizarre Contraption a
collection of components that didn't
seem to be in any logical configuration
however it was primarily composed of
something that Eric recognized All Too
Well a chest table this one was metal
steel to be precise and seemed to be
hooked up to some sort of computer while
back in the 9s computers were hardly as
common place as they are now Eric had
seen a fair few at school and the
library although this one was different
it seemed old far older than Eric
thought computers had been around for as
far as he knew they'd only really come
to prominence in the mid 80s but this
computer looked like it predated even
that period noticing another part of the
contraption a large steam engine with
the words manufactured by modlay Suns
and field established 1840 engraved on
one side made it seemed that this whole
device had been around since the
Victorian era the next part that caught
his eyes was the the chest pieces
themselves each one standing neatly in
its place on the board they looked
delicate intricately carved from some
smooth substance for a moment Eric toyed
with a thought of how they could even be
made from bone noticing how each Pawn
Knight Rook Bishop king and queen were
all about the size of a human finger
bone he dismissed the idea nobody would
ever do something like
that Eric grabbed a sheet covering a
large component hooked up to the mess
lifting it away in a swift pole it
unveiled what was sitting beneath a full
Suite of 18th century Samurai armor Eric
to looked closer at the embellishments
on the surface of the paldrons he was no
expert on feudal Japan but it looked
authentic enough to be the real thing if
not a very close approximation taking a
look at the collection of oddies all
tethered together in his father's lab a
certain detail of all his chess research
came to the Forefront of Eric's mind the
armor that had given it away this was
the samurai or at the very least a crude
homemade version of it that his dad had
put together but if it worked it was
also something to practice against it
didn't take Eric long to start tinkering
with the contraption trying to get it to
work all the while the question of why
his dad owned such a thing kept drumming
up noise in the back of his head had
Brian built it or was this the original
made by that Russian chess prodigy was
this machine the reason that Eric's dad
possessed such an unbeatable skill at
chess and would using it give him the
edge he needed to best him at the game
and earn his father's respect after what
felt like hours upon hours of trial and
error with a machine he could barely
comprehend Eric seemed to have cracked
it as far as he could tell the steam
engine powered the whole Contraption and
could be set to five different speeds
labeled on the side in Roman numerals
the power from the engine was then fed
to some kind of C sophisticated
mechanism that was within the suit of
Samurai armor allowing it to move and
what appeared to be a series of
electromagnets that moved the chest
pieces and kept them on the board
flicking it onto the third highest of
the five speed levels the machine word
into life the sound of creaking and
grinding of metal filled the lab
kneeling opposite Eric went to make the
first move only to stop himself it
wasn't that he changed his mind about
practicing against the samurai but
because because of the speed he'd set it
to determining that the settings might
have correlated to difficulty levels
Eric figured that if he really wanted to
get the most rigorous practice to really
hone his chest moves he needed to commit
fully reaching for the dial he turned
the device up to its Fifth and highest
speed then made his first move he pushed
one of the bone colored prawns forward
by a single square and waited a split
second passed and the arm of the early
automaton responded with its first
counter move it was quick almost moving
with the same natural fluidity and speed
as an actual human being albeit still
with a little bit of creaking and some
slight Clockwork like stutters but it
worked nonetheless the machine could
play the tension over the first game was
palpable forming a layer of sweat over
Eric's forehead every were and tick of
the machine gave the impression that
they were playing with a stop clock
timing each of their moves adding to the
urgency despite this Eric Matthews tried
his best to stay calm this was practice
after all a dry run not the inevitable
game he'd play against his dad with
every move he made his heart drummed
against his ribs uncertain he'd made the
right call each time the robotic hand
cruy knocked over one of his Pieces away
Eric felt a surge of frustration but
told himself to quell it he kept focused
using what he'd researched to adapt and
respond accordingly to each of the
machines moves until Checkmate he'd
beaten it he might have lost everything
everything Sav for a knight a rook his
king and queen but he had won trapped
without anywhere else to move on the
board the metal finger of the automaton
conceded the Game knocking over its own
King in resignation panting heart rcing
from the sheer excitement of being on
The Winning Side of A game Eric hurly
gathered up and reset all the pieces he
had to go again not just so that he
could be certain it wasn't a fluke but
to make sure he had what it took to take
on his Professor father back and forth
Eric went with the chess machine over
and over again they were fairly evenly
matched it seemed Eric won the second
game only to be best on the next two but
it was sometime afterward he had lost
count of exactly how many rounds later
that things started to change maybe it
was the age and condition of the
Victorian era chess computer the natural
wear and tear stopping it from
functioning properly But Eric noticed
that the samurai started to make moves
that were illogical that practically
offered him the upper hand with no
discernable strategy behind them then
its movements became Flatout illegal
disregarding the directions and number
of squares each different piece was
allowed to move before long it was
moving them erratically around the
chessboard refusing to cooperate and
forcing Eric to call an end to the days
practicing unfortunately it wouldn't be
the end of the unusual things that would
happen that day did you send me that
weird email was the first question
Eric's dad asked him when he returned
home looking noticeably under the
weather confused Eric said that he had
no idea what his father was talking
about Professor Matthews then went on to
describe what he'd received on his work
computer it had been an email with a
file attached to it named Shak a word in
Russian that translates to chess
embedded in the email below although it
had taken a long time to load being
opened on a 1990s computer there had
apparently been a photo as well it was
rather odd Eric Brian went on quite
unnerving to tell the truth black and
white all sort of distorted and
stretched but it looked like two young
girls one grinning and the other
screaming I've been feeling well not
quite myself since I saw it with that
Brian excused himself stating that he'd
been suffering from headaches and a high
temperature and as a result needed to go
and lay down it wasn't like his father
to get ill Eric thought but of course he
had no reason to assume it was anything
serious probably just a speed of f after
a long day of teaching at the University
no cause for concern if only that's all
it was within a few hours Brian was
completely restless so unable to sleep
that simply taking a nap was impossible
he kept calling to Eric complaining of
the sound of childlike laughter coming
from somewhere in the house but his son
hadn't heard anything by the time the
sun went down Eric was trying to calm
his dad down through a rush of intense
anxiety that gripped him Brian had been
claimed to be hallucinating seeing the
Warped faces of two girls that
frightened him half to death it was
getting late long past the time that
they usually played chest together but
for now Eric's mind was focused solely
on helping his dad for a while he seemed
to be able to calm his father down only
to realize Brian wasn't settled at all
he was awake eyes open fully conscious
but wasn't responding at all to Eric
asking if he was all right instead the
accomplished academic just stared
blankly into space Eric had been up all
night exhausted worried for Brian's
safety and completely clueless about
what was happening to him after a while
being non-responsive his dad seemed to
regain a little bit of Lucidity once
more but his behavior was erratic take
me back to work I I need to get on my
computer Brian demanded of his son when
Eric refused that's when his dad got
angry and agitated Professor Brian
Matthews was sadly found dead within the
next few months several months later as
the sole executive of his father's
estate and last living relative Eric had
to be the one to go through his dad's
personal belongings volumes upon volumes
of thick academic books his smart
scholarly clothes the house was almost
clear now save for one thing that was
left in the basement lab flicking on the
light switch Eric looked at the samurai
sitting motionless still uncovered after
their last practice game he'd sold off
the chest pieces to a collector in New
York now it was just an empty odity Eric
placed a king on the board one of the
ones that he and his dad had used when
they played each other with a gentle
flick of his finger he toppled it
resigning to the strange automaton and
leaving it there in the laboratory he
wasn't sure how but he had some kind of
gut feeling that this chess machine had
somehow been responsible for his
father's fate of course Eric had no idea
what the device actually was and what or
who lay beneath its woring metal Parts
SCP 1875 is the designation given into
this machine now and has been ever since
the foundation recovered it not long
after Eric sold his father's house they
are able to learn much more about it
than young Mr Matthews or even the late
professor Matthews ever had not just how
to make it work or what its function was
but who had built it and who had been
used to build it although details of his
real name eluded the foundation's top
researchers they were able to uncover
newspaper articles about the device from
all over Russia America and England
dating back to the early 1990s the
Russian chess Prodigy who' invented it
and toured the chess playing machine
around had used some interesting
components to make his automaton maybe
they were what derived its skill at the
game and its apparent temperament when
the device was made to play at maximum
speed for too long he had used his
daughters to make the machine deep
within the heart of this early form of
computer the two girls brain tissue had
been hooked up to the electromagnets The
Machine's moves were theirs each Pawn or
Rook shifting across the black and white
squares of the board every rule or
strategy their Prodigy father had taught
it all determined how the device played
their minds taken from their skulls were
now the analytical engine of their
father's creation the bones of their
fingers he' carved into chest pieces
over the coming weeks the foundation
naturally ran their usual slew of tests
on SCP
1875 playing multiple games of chess
against it every time they increased the
machine's five levels of speed until it
started behaving erratically while on
the highest setting shortly after every
member of personnel working on SCP 1875
received a bizarre email it contained a
file named with the Russian word for
chess and a photograph of the stretched
distorted smiling and screaming faces of
two young girls faces that you might be
seeing very soon for many Avid video
game fans those who just can't get
enough of grinding away for hours on
quests battling endless enemies and
exploring infinite Virtual Worlds
Landing a job as a gameplay tester seems
like the perfect opportunity doing your
favorite thing in the world and getting
paid to do it well that's the dream plus
the added benefit of seeing how the
sausage gets made of getting access to a
game still in development and suggesting
ways it can be improved think of all the
gaming disasters that might have been
avoided with a few more play testers in
the room looking at you Fallout New
Vegas and your NPCs with the spinning
heads well One Gamer had the same
thought a young man by the name of Danny
wheeler when he spotted an ad seeking
beta play testers for an invelopment RPG
from an upand cominging indie game
Studio he jumped at the chance to apply
the pay wasn't amazing but it was
definitely a better gig than his current
job at the local convenience store
Hawking energy drinks to snarky teens
and counting down the hours until he
could get back home kick up his feet and
get away from it all with a controller
in his hand but sometimes things that
seem too good to be true actually are at
first Danny had a perfectly enjoyable
time testing the game it was standard
RPG fantasy fod and though he made sure
to inform the developers that he found
the steampunk aesthetic to be a little
bit played out at this point there was
nothing at all notable about it it was
fine but the development team kept going
on and on about the Tactical heuristic
algorithms and how the game was meant to
learn the more the player played so Dany
was instructed to log as many hours of
this exceedingly average game as
possible he sat at his desk for hours
sipping on an extra- large soda and
clicking away fighting Orcs goblins and
more slowly the difficulty began to
increase and the game started to grow on
him a bit he even developed a favorite
character to play as the Rogue with his
stealth and proficiency for close range
combat the more he played as the Rogue
however the more he started to notice
the game's characters behaving
differently enemies were attacking him
with ranged weapons from far away they
were setting traps to ruin his
character's stealthy approach and catch
him in the ACT then the game started to
glitch a lot to the point of becoming
nearly unplayable enemies would fall to
the ground as if Dead when he hadn't
dealt them a single blow as he started
to walk his characters away from them
they would suddenly spring back to life
and St right before he could even think
about a defense if he didn't know any
better he could swear the game's
characters were deliberately trying to
trick him it only got more frustrating
from there with enemies making sudden
loud sounds to catch him off guard and
startle him out of concentration and
other character staring down the barrel
of the camera with serious unblinking
eyes as if they could see him through
his monitor one day he fired up the game
to see that its characters somehow had
rearranged various torches to spell out
you'll never imag bound to anything
Danny your dad was right it took a ton
of torches and Danny couldn't help but
take it personally that was the last
straw he returned the game to the studio
and resigned from his position he got
enough insults working in customer
service he didn't need to take that kind
of talk from a video game though he
didn't know it Dany got out not a moment
too soon other play testers were not as
lucky particularly One Man Who Would
sadly lose his life as Danny intuited
this was no ordinary video game it was
unusual enough to draw the attention of
the SCP Foundation who would go on to
designate it SCP
1633 SCP 1633 is an anomalous computer
game created by a now defunct
independent game Studio the copy
currently being held by the foundation
is believed to be a beta version of the
game while the core gameplay is
relatively complete there are numerous
missing assets the music is largely
either missing or placeholder music and
the game is plagued by a large number of
graphical glitches because of the
generally buggy and glitchy nature of
the game the foundation considered both
Todd Howard and CD project red to be
major people and groups of interest in
the case however the discovery of other
key suspects eventually absolved them of
Suspicion for now this version of the
game was compiled 2 days before the
foundation raided the office of the
studio and is therefore believed to be
the most complete version of the game in
existence to be more specific about the
actual nature of the game itself SCP
1633 is a squad-based RPG with a
third-person camera perspective the
action is seen from an elevated
perspective with all characters on
screen aesthetically the game world is
steampunk and features various fantasy
creatures as enemies including elves
dwarves Orcs goblins Etc fitting with
the steampunk style the game's urban
areas are modeled after Victorian era
London the four-player characters are a
band of Outlaws hired by the sin Arch
Duke of bodri to investigate a theft
however as the game progresses it
becomes a battle to save the entire
world as an ancient all powerful being
known as Kar intends to wake from its
Thousand-Year Slumber and Destroy
Humanity the player controls a squad of
four characters with direct control over
one character at a time and a command
menu to control the other three It is
believed that in the game's finished
State a multiplayer option that would
have allowed four different real world
players to cooperate is likely to have
been included like many squad-based
games each character has a different
specialty The Marksman uses longrange
weapons The Alchemist has access to
potions and chemicals with various
effects the Rogue can move stealthily
and assassinate enemies and the thug has
greater Health than the other characters
and does more melee damage and as is
also typical for games of this variety
XP earn from completing challenges and
killing enemies throughout the game
allows for players to upgrade the
abilities and stats of their characters
while the story and core gameplay
mechanics are nothing special there is
one element that pushes SCP 1633 into
anomalous territory and it's also the
element that would have been front and
center in a Finnish games marketing
campaign it's quote tactical heuristic
algorithms these work in a unique
fashion whenever a player finishes a
session and saves their game the game
will begin running lengthy background
processes when these processes are
complete a ptd or player tactical data
file is saved on the computer when the
save file and by extension the
associated ptd file is loaded the
enemies and challenges in the game will
have become far more effective tailoring
their methods to the particular skills
and tactics of the player the extent to
which this happened is proportional to
the amount of time spent playing the
game this kind of Technology may seem
theoretically possible but the extent to
which the game pushes it causes it to
rest in anomalous territory the game's
programming is so intelligent that it
can tell simply by the tiniest clues in
your play style if you're loading a file
that isn't your own it will then pause
the game and make you load your own save
file and the tactics employed by the
enemies in the game as they learn more
about the player are nothing short of
frightening at first the enemies will
adapt to the player's preferred weapons
strategies and overall play style then
they will realize that the player
character is controlled by an external
Force meaning of course you and begin to
mount psychological attacks directly on
the player through numerous tests the
foundation has been able to build a kind
of framework for the average player
experience through this framework we're
able to track and correlate average play
time with the average adaptability of
SCP 1633 to the player it is worth
noting that these effects do not apply
if the game is completed in a single
continuous playthrough for the purposes
of this experiment the game was stopped
saved and restarted at regular intervals
allowing the game to collect player
tactical data during the first 2 hours
the game's AI is abysmal with enemies
simply charging at the players with no
strategy whatsoever and typically being
mowed down however from 2 to 5 hours the
enemies undergo intelligence growth
adapting their play style to the types
of weapons they carry and their
environments at this stage this combat
level is also about equal to an
untrained human Z civilian from 5 to 8
hours enemies become considerably more
proficient and then begin countering the
player on their specific play Styles and
techniques for example they will attack
a player who uses longrange Weaponry
from cover with grenades or Splash
damage weapons to force them out into
the open they will also fully utilize
their environment for both defensive and
offensive purposes laying traps and
creating ambushes to surprise and kill
players at this point their combat
skills are equal to train soldiers from
8 to 12 hours the focus of the enemy
shifts from attacking the player
character to attacking the player
directly they engage in behaviors that
from an online playing perspective would
be considered griefing such as
intentionally blocking the players's
view or movement within the game enemies
have also been known to exploit player
expectations pretending to be broken or
glitched to make the player let their
guard down and then killing them in one
play session the enemies begin throwing
day flash spells similar to real life
flashbang grenades at the player they
throw them in a manner that created a
strobing effect causing the player to
have a Grand Mall seizure Beyond 12
hours the enemies engage in advanced
psychological tactics against the player
with methods that range wildly and tend
to be specific to the player's mindset
and play style for example one player
likes to exert a high level of control
over all four of their squad members in
response enemies used attacks that did
little or no damage but caused the
characters to become dazed a state which
temporarily disrupts player control
however rather than attack the dazed
characters enemies simply surround them
in a crowd continually using days
attacks to prevent the player from doing
anything this caused major frustration
for the player enemies may also attempt
to induce psychological Terror among the
players in one example enemies somehow
kidnapped one of the four player
characters and dragged them off screen
when this character was later found
found they were strapped to a kind of
sacrificial altar this caused
considerable anxiety for the player it
seems that this is the upper limit of
the game's anomalous powers in most
cases meaning things typically level off
after 12 hours unless a specific entity
appears to be inhabiting the game which
you'll learn more about later in order
to discover the prior information the
SCP Foundation performed a series of
tests on the game with various different
subjects in test 001 Junior researcher
Ross an experienced gamer who was
pivotal in first discovering the anomaly
skipped ahead of the typical preliminary
declass tests seeing as he was already
eager for the game's nonanomalous
release he was also eager to be the
first in line to try it out on the
foundation's dime being a gamer Ross
also found a number of glitches and
exploits in the game to improve his
performance allowing him to run rings
around his enemies however as expected
the enemies adapted to Ross's techniques
after Gathering his player tactical data
first they just began using their
weapons and exploiting the environments
more effectively but they didn't stop
there soon they became aware of the same
exploits Ross was using before
exploiting them themselves and using it
to beat him repeatedly in the end they
moved to the psychological stage forcing
Ross into a glitch that rendered him
unable to move he tried to free his
character for several minutes until
realizing he couldn't and rage quit the
game in test 00 2 they used a d-class
designated D
22930 he was a man with proven anger
issues even down to murdering his prior
girlfriend in a jealous rage initially
he enjoyed the game choosing the thug
character type and taking out his
aggression on the many enemies however
as time went on the enemies became wise
to his tactic and began their
psychological attacks they gathered
around the DCL class's player character
dropping their weapons but the Swarm
became so tightly packed around the
character that he couldn't even move
this started to cause major frustration
when the character attempted to charge
through the enemies attacked killing him
with their bare hands in test 014 the
foundation brought in an agent with
special forces experiences with Advanced
knowledge in tactical combat however
even she was worn down and defeated over
time as the enemies adapted to and
exploited her tactics the foundation
even considered using SCP 1633 three as
a tool for developing effective
countertactics in their real life
operations in test 021 the foundation
used a d-class with vast experience in
the world of commercial gaming he was
told to complete the game in one
playthrough taking pauses rather than
proper breaks as predicted with no time
to run the background processes and
create player tactical data files the
enemies weren't able to improve and the
d-class was able to complete the game in
around 13 hours however the game did
create a player tactical data file in
the aftermath of this playthrough and
used it to offer a new game plus mode to
the d-class when he began to play this
new game the screen displayed a
seemingly random pattern of black and
white pixels visually similar to
television static this image appeared to
be Cognito hazardous as it caused
Catatonia and later death for the player
and what felt like a decidedly Petty
move for SCP
1633 as alluded to earlier the game was
first discovered by Junior researcher
Ross who was an avid follower of the
independent game Studio initially
producing the game however while
frequenting developer fan forums he
found that various members of the team
were quitting the project for seemingly
bizarre reasons well this wasn't enough
on its own for the foundation to
intervene it was what first attracted
official attention they moved in after
the death of Gregor Tilman a game tester
for the company who died not long after
joining the project the foundation moved
in in and after that gain control
shutting down the studio and taking
everything they had all anomalous
elements were isolated secured and
contained any loose ends were given
amnestics and recorded data on the
anomalous artifacts were destroyed it's
believed that one classified female
member of the dev team was behind the
anomalous nature of the game but she was
able to escape and has since attempted
to join other development teams she is
now considered an active person of
interest and is being pursued by mobile
task force MW 6 6 AKA don't hate the
player some final disturbing details are
recorded in a note left by the game
tester Gregor Tilman the note seized by
the foundation and included in SCP 1633
official file reads as follows I'm
writing this on paper cuz I don't think
he can learn it he got everything
digital real quick but I've unplugged
the router and broke my phone so I think
he's trapped in here but he won't stop
talking talking talking all the time at
the start of this job they told me all
about the tactical algorithm stuff man
I've been playing games all my life and
I knew I could beat it I I knew I could
handle this when I started playing the
game they learned quickly they kept
using the sniper rifle and after like an
hour they learned how to use cover then
another couple hours they'd set ambushes
then another hour and they started
sniping back while having a different
Squad flank me after that they figured
out how to glitch the physics engine and
ride crates at me or duck under the
floor they were learning but all that
was just easy stuff it was Evol ution
man one bit figures something out so it
survives longer than the others it
wasn't directed after act three kraar
shows up he's supposed to be like this
Lovecraft Cosmic horror Crazy Monster
who can read the player's mind and
corrupt your soul he showed up right
after I killed strict the blood Drinker
that big spider monster he's supposed to
have this long speech about how I killed
his General on this plane and now he
needs to intervene directly or something
but instead he talked about how I was a
worthy adversary but I was cheating
because I was on another plan
cnar wasn't like the other enemies
because he wasn't supposed to be he was
supposed to be smart he was supposed to
know everything so he did he'd been
watching his minions fight me the whole
time and he knew everything they did it
wasn't just random mutations anymore it
was plann it wasn't Evolution man it was
actual intelligent design I brought it
home I had to know more I'm sorry but I
had to I copied the latest compile and
installed it on my home box and brought
my save game and that other file with me
on a flash drive it was the same a there
he kept talking to me about how I was
keeping him from fulfilling his purpose
by keeping him trapped in a glass jar no
matter where I went in the game he kept
shouting and ranting then he did more at
first it was just slowing down in my
other programs the drive chugging when
it shouldn't be then the next time I
played the game he started talking about
my screen plays all the enemies looked
like me I guess he could see through the
webcam he started needling me about
Jenny reading me bits of her emails
acting out the breakup he found the
videos of her and started making the
enemies in her voice then he was
everywhere on my computer I uninstalled
the game but he was still there he kept
opening documents and typing to me
calling me a foul cheat and a lowly worm
telling me to fight him on the same
plane as soon as I realized he was
outside the game I shut down my router
pulled out the network card but I don't
know if I got them quickly enough maybe
he got out I turned the computer off but
he kept turning it back on I wanted to
break it but I didn't know if that would
kill him maybe it wouldn't maybe it
would let him out I tried leaving the
house but it was like I could still hear
him I couldn't leave him alone because
he might get out or do something else I
can't sleep haven't slept since he came
out I've been here for 3 days and I
can't leave I can't leave him he keeps
telling me to release him but I can't I
want to kill him but I don't know if I
can I I can't think anymore I have to
kill kill kill him before he does
anything new he won't stop talking and I
can't keep thinking I can't keep going
I'm sorry I have to go now I'm sorry I'm
sorry after studying the note carefully
the foundation conducted a thorough
investigation for any other
manifestations of this cnar entity no
mentions of it were found on any of the
other devices in tilman's apartment nor
did a web search on the subject turn up
any relevant results at this time it is
believed that the entity whatever it was
or whatever it was attempting to do was
destroyed along with Tillman's computer
which he appeared to have taken apart
smashed and burned in a metal trash can
whatever tormented to him during his
last days on Earth is gone now
thankfully because the foundation
currently owns the only copy of the game
and the game's anomalous effects are
only evident to active players SCP 1633
poses no risk of containment breach and
therefore it has been given the object
class safe one copy of SCP 1633 is
stored on a standard DVD ROM in a secure
storage locker in site 15 along with all
supporting documentation and ancillary
materials any playthroughs of the game
must be approved by project head Dr
burer and all of said playthroughs are
to be monitored closely and subject to
strict rules after all this is one game
that doesn't play fair ask anyone who
has ever lived in a small town and
they'll most likely all tell you the
same exact thing the worst part isn't
just being far away from the nearest
city or distant from friends and family
it's the boredom that gets you having so
little nearby gives you so few options
for things to fill your time with for
some they get used to it as they grow
old spending their life in the same tiny
Community they either learn to make
their own entertainment or just get used
to the boredom drowning It Out by
sitting and watching TV all day but
others they just can't stand being bored
being stuck somewhere with nothing
interesting to do and ultimately they
can end up getting so sick of it that
there's only one option leave pack their
bags and hit the road up sticks and move
to a new place far from the small town
they were born in thing is leaving isn't
cheap moving to a new town a big city or
even an entirely different state is a
luxury that costs a pretty penny some
might work and save their wages until
they can realize that dream of moving
away but not everyone has that much
patience some Want to Be Free of the
board them as soon as they can maybe
they might apply to be a contestant on a
game show chance at all and try to win
themselves a big cash prize sure it's a
hell of a Gamble and a loss might mean
humiliation in front of everyone you
know and more but winning could be your
ticket away from small town living that
might be easier said than done though
not only does someone looking to move
away need to be picked as a contestant
they also need to play by the rules and
actually win the game but as if that
wasn't enough they also have to live to
tell about it for as long as she could
remember cat had always hated it here
her hometown was Tiny too small to
include more than the main street with
few local stores the one school that
everyone who had ever lived there had
studied at and little else of note and
as for things people could do for fun in
the town well as you can probably
imagine the options were severely
limited especially for a group of
teenagers like cat and her friends most
of the time all that she and the others
Leo Ricky and Dany could do to pass the
time was sit in the back of Ricky's
truck and park in the middle of town
watching people and waiting for
something even mildly interesting to
happen not that it ever did the four of
them had a name for the rest of the
town's folk everyone that had lived
there for their entire lives and never
dared to venture anywhere else lifers as
in they were imprisoned serving a life
sentence in this small town never to
escape or move on or make something of
themselves as much as they likeed to
poke fun at those people each of the
group knew that every weekend they
wasted just sitting around the closer
they were getting to One Day become
lifers themselves we need to just go cat
would say trying to Rally the other
three into taking a spontaneous trip
away as a group just load up the truck
one day pick a Direction and drive until
we find somewhere Ricky and Leo would
nod their heads in agreement and Danny
would talk for hours all about the
places she might like to go to one day
but none of them ever actually made any
plans to leave nobody knew where to
start until they heard rumors about an
abandoned TV studio just outside of town
apparently according to Danny's older
brother it had been there for years just
sitting there completely empty it wasn't
just a small local Studio either one of
the big National networks had owned it
and used to film there regularly back in
the day why would someone set up a
studio here of all places had been Leo's
immediate response look at where we live
cat replied it's the literal middle of
nowhere the network must have got the
land Dirt Cheap the real question is why
don't we go and check it out what for
Danny asked cat silently gestured at the
cramped Main Street that surrounded them
the place that may as well have been the
center of the known universe to the four
Teenage friends do you see anything else
to do around here before long the four
of them were in agreement Ricky's truck
pulled up in front of their houses in
the middle of the night and under the
cover of Darkness they drove out towards
what was left of the TV studio this was
it they were finally going somewhere
beyond the choking cramped confines of
their tiny Hometown although whether or
not they'd all make it back was another
matter here's a hard lesson for you kids
You Can't Fight For Life you believe you
deserve if you don't have a little skin
in the game with home a few miles in the
rearview mirror the truck stopped at a
chain link fence a pair of signs were
hanging from it one welcoming them to
the studio while the other
simultaneously warned them to keep out
that this area was private property
ignoring it the four of them stepped out
of the truck and started to climb the
fence throwing Leo's jacket over the top
to avoid injury beyond the fence was a
huge building almost the size of a
warehouse with a door marked Studio
entrance that practically invited the
Intrepid teens to open it up and have a
look inside each one of them carrying a
torch in hand the group walked up to the
abandoned studio and gently PRI open the
door trying not to make too much noise
even though they knew the whole place
was abandoned they still didn't want to
attract too much attention and get
caught trespassing the lights were all
dead as cat led the group her hand being
tightly squeezed by Dany next to her the
two boys behind none of them had been
sure what to expect it wasn't exactly
like anyone in the group had ever set
foot inside a TV studio before but they
were met with a narrow concrete walled
Corridor so underwhelming that it almost
made it extraordinary in just how
profoundly dull it was lifting his torch
Leo pointed out some lettering on the
wall that read to tmdg set with an arrow
pointing the four friends further down
the corridor naturally driven by her
curiosity and need to be literally
anywhere where apart from her hometown
cat followed the Arrow's direction to
another door pushing it open she stepped
inside her torch light immediately being
blocked by a thick curtain brushing her
hand against the material she started
looking for a parting but before she
could welcome
contestants a voice boomed through the
dark coming from somewhere in the space
beyond the curtain instantly Danny
screamed at the sound almost wrenching
cat's arm off in sheer surprise before
we Begin The Voice continued I need you
all to tell me are you ready cat shot a
look back at Ricky the friend furthest
behind her fumbling with the door they'd
entered through it was locked he
couldn't get it to budge he turned and
met cat's gaze shaking his head uh sure
we're ready Leo suddenly piped up
calling out to answer the voice before
the rest of the group could turn and
glare at him the curtain around them
lifted so much bright light came pouring
in that it practically days the four of
them each taking a moment to readjust
when her vision cleared cat saw they
were standing in a huge Sound Stage
blinding spotlights pointing at her and
her friends from somewhere above with
seating area big enough to seat their
Town's entire population in that case
folks you know what time it is came the
voice again talking as if there was a
live studio audience present despite
every chair being unoccupied these four
lucky Challengers will go head-to-head
each one looking to take on the victory
as well as a huge mystery prize but only
if they dare to take on the most
dangerous game there was a pause as if
this unseen announcer was waiting for a
round of applause without warning more
lights came on Illuminating the space in
front of the four very confused friends
standing before them was what looked
like part of an obstacle course a series
of four horizontal beams over an empty
space the glare of the light was so
intense that even squint hting cat
couldn't tell what was beneath it just
looked like a void nothing but total
darkness with four narrow beams Bridging
the Gap between where they stood and
another platform Beyond well what are
you all standing around waiting for the
announcer declared almost mocking the
14s urging them the rules of course
there was another awkward pause like the
voice was waiting for laughter it's
simple the four of you will be competing
to make it through each of our obstacles
make it to the end before our timer hit
Zer and you'll be tonight's big winner
but fall behind or cheat and it's out
with you a huge Digital Countdown
illuminated on one side of the sound
stage telling the group they only had 10
minutes to play Kat Leo Danny and Ricky
barely had a chance to question what was
going on exchanging quick concerned
looks before the announcer started
urgently counting them down 3 2 1 he
cheered simultaneously the four
teenagers felt felt a presence looming
behind them like a figure was standing
just out of view blocking them from
turning back carefully putting one foot
in front of the other cat started
shimmying along the beam in front of her
trying to keep herself steady while also
moving as fast as she could without
falling out of the corner of her eye she
could also see Dany on the beam next to
her doing the same but finding it a
little easier to balance Leo was having
no problem at all Sid stepping with
enough speed to keep him practically
neck and neck with cat but Ricky was
wobbling
every foot he placed on the beam he felt
like it might give way beneath him but
it was just a game show right sure it
shouldn't even really be running right
now but regardless of why or how the
worst that could happen was that he
would fall his next step missed the beam
entirely and Ricky could feel himself
toppling guys he called out to his
friends trying to shift his weight onto
his back leg cat Danny and Leo all froze
and snapped their heads back to look at
him just in time to see Ricky wildly
flailing his arms his whole body body
toppled to one side and he dropped off
the beam with a loud scream not one of
them saw him land or even heard it for
that matter it was as if Ricky had just
been swallowed up whole by the Dark Void
beneath them his scream getting more and
more distant until it couldn't be heard
anymore oh tough break talk about
falling at the first hurdle The Voice
exclaimed as if what had just happened
was some kind of joke so long Ricky we
hardly knew you staying perfectly still
but clearly stressed Danny called out
Ricky's name there was no answer cat
just stared wide-eyed at the abyss below
only looking away as she heard Leo
jumped the last bit of his beam onto the
platform Danny come on cat whispered to
her friend who looked back at her with
tears streaming down her face the pair
of them carefully stepped further along
their respective beams trying to stop
themselves from looking down or at the
huge clock seconds ticking away and
putting them under even more undue
pressure reaching the other side Danny
dropped to her knees un able to hold
back her sobbing kneeling down to
comfort her cat looked up at the sound
stage's bright lights for any sign of
who was putting them through this bring
Ricky back she yelled I'm sorry the
announcer replied the game show bravado
dropping from their voice but you agreed
to play he'll be fine Leo said bet you
anything he just screamed like that to
scare us Leo you don't seriously believe
that cat asked as she helped Danny stand
up wiping her friend's tears away is he
dead she sobbed I don't know cat replied
honestly of course he's not Leo
interjected it's a Sound Stage it's not
like this place is dangerous then why
was it abandoned Danny asked Leo didn't
give her an answer either because he was
distracted by the lights coming up on
the next part of the obstacle course or
because he didn't know and wouldn't
admit it ahead of them was a long
stretch of the course forming a narrow
square-shaped walkway wide portions of
the top side were dropping to the bottom
in regular intervals separating the
tight space space before opening it up
again every time the segments lifted up
the three remaining contestants could
see all the way to the other side of the
walkway where a new platform waited for
them with Danny under one arm cat looked
at the far end of the walkway as it
disappeared and reappeared behind the
rising and falling segments then she
noticed the timer the seconds rapidly
ticking down but Leo had noticed it too
and turned to look at the two girls with
a determined expression cat shook her
head at him but it was too late with all
strength Leo shoved Danny and Cat both
of them Landing flat on their backs on
the platform he bolted towards the
walkway as fast as he could managing to
dodge between each portion pausing as
they came down only to run into the next
one as they lifted back up helping Dany
back to her feet cat ran after Leo he
already had a head start and would
easily make it to the other side of the
walkway before the girls so instead cat
held Danny close and took it slow
methodically waiting for each segment to
lift back up before they went further
into into the next safe Zone they were
gaining on Leo who was sprinting to the
Finish between the rise and fall of the
ceiling's crushing weight cat watched
him disappear behind each block only to
see his back when it came back up he had
made it to the platform opposite panting
but otherwise unscathed when she next
lost sight of him that's when the
announcer spoke up again now now Leo it
said that was hardly fair was it and we
all know what happens when you break the
rules as the the segment in front of her
and Danny rose again cat caught sight of
Leo just ahead but it was what was
standing behind him that stopped her in
her tracks two huge figures each like a
shadow without anything casting it
towered over Leo one of them reached
forward and grabbed him shrouding him in
a quo of darkness and he was gone just
like Ricky he vanished cat had been so
transfixed by what she had just
witnessed that she didn't notice where
she was standing right under a block
that was about to drop grabbing her her
hand again Denny pulled her out of the
path of the descending slab cat felt it
brush against the back of her leg just
as the pair of them made it out on the
other end and onto the platform the last
two contestants and then their work too
the announcer cheered pausing again for
a reaction from the empty room we don't
want to play this sick game anymore
Danny yelled well you made it this far
the Unseen host replied time for our
third and final challenge the final
stretch of the course make it through
this and you're home free but fail Or
Break The Rules like Leo and you'll be
disqualified game over it's okay Danny
cat whispered whatever's next we'll get
through it do you think the boys will
come back if we do her friend asked just
like Leo had cat didn't answer the
lights revealed the last stretch of the
course the final platform was overhead a
net climbing wall in front of them it
was a straight vertical Ascent up with a
wall behind the next and holes in it its
surface wasting no time both cat and
Danny started climbing up the rungs of
the thick rope staying level with each
other as they went higher and then
they're off look at them go ladies and
gentlemen the announcer commented still
speaking as if to an audience but it's
not going to be so easy the sharp sound
of metal made both girls gasp as long
spikes shot forward from the holes in
the wall the blades retracted
fortunately having Miss Danny and Cat
this time what had started as a simple
clim up had become something akin to a
twisted game of whack-a-mole with each
of them trying to avoid staying in front
of the holes in the wall for too long
dodging the spikes as they went in and
out they climbed higher and higher until
cat Danny screamed she looked over her
shoulder only to noticed she was in the
lead below her Dany was calling up to
her with a fear-stricken expression her
foot was caught in the rigging of the
net kicking and thrashing wildly to try
and free it cat looked back up she was
almost at the platform close enough to
nearly reach it with her fingertips but
behind her her friend was stuck and with
no idea when the spikes would come next
shooting out of the wall cat threw
herself over the edge of the platform
and landed on her back just as she heard
the gut-wrenching sound of the spikes
extending ring out she was beside
herself tears streaming down her face it
wasn't uncommon for people to be
overwhelmed to the point of tears at the
end of a game show but cat wasn't crying
with joy we have a winner the
disembodied voice declared barely
audible to the surviving contestant as
she wept after she'd finished explaining
what had happened to the police a group
of mysterious agents flocked to the
Sound Stage to lock it down stopping
anyone else from getting close to it
they'd found a VHS tape in the mailbox
at the front office of the studio on it
was a recording of a game show a live
audience cheering as one by one Ricky
Leo and Dany failed to complete the
course one of the SCP Foundation agents
had come to interview cat asking her to
recount the whole story all over again
her account lined up perfectly with
everything seen on the tape then the
agent asked her what her prize had been
after she won a car cat replied the four
of us always wanted to leave home it's
frightening to think about how many
people go missing each year
approximately 1600 individuals
mysteriously vanish each year in
National Parks alone one moment they're
there making their way down a hiking
trail or stopping for a granola bar by a
lake and the next they're gone missing
people are an unfortunate fact of life
one we all just try to put out of our
minds as we silently hope we and those
we know and love will be fortunate
enough to avoid joining the ranks of the
lost but some places some very strange
obscure places nestled in the quiet
Countryside and tucked away under
blankets of fog lose so many people that
it becomes well anomalous one particular
town a seemingly innocuous place place
with a thriving tourism industry was the
sight of so many unexplained
disappearances that had drew the
attention of the SCP Foundation they
dispatched a team to enter the town to
gather as many facts and figures as they
could and to see what exactly had become
of these missing people leading the team
was none other than the sometimes
Fearless often Shameless Dr Jack brght
how did the infamous Dr brght get here
well for many employees of the SCP
Foundation leading a task force to
investigate a new potentially anomalous
location would be a promotion or a
welcome diversion from yet another round
of testing to see if maybe something
will finally destroy SCP 682 but in this
particular case it was a matter of
discipline after Dr brgh was caught
giving scp-999 a triple shot of espresso
to quote just see what would happen he
was assigned to fieldwork as part of his
punishment for the record what happened
was as SCP 999 ricocheting off the walls
at such a high speed and intensity that
it broke several Windows damaged the
ceiling and knocked out the power for
half of the site and so Dr Brite found
himself with a task force of foundation
operatives trudging reluctantly through
beautiful but boring rural New England
toward the town of Interest as he drove
down the winding road grumbling to
himself and wishing he could be anywhere
else he spotted the sign marking their
intended destination welcome to Silent
Hill
up ahead a thick fog rolling off the
lake covered the town in the dim gray
blur he couldn't make out anything
through the unnaturally dense Haze he
squinted and turned on the high beams
but the light did nothing to cut through
the fog bouncing off of it like a
billowing curtain of white just as they
passed the sign the van began to slow
rapidly its engine sputtering and
grinding as the vehicle skitted to a
sudden stop damn it Dr brigh thumped the
steering wheel in frustration any of you
know how to fix fix a car he looked at
the team of operatives in the back seat
they all Shrugged noncommittally the
only thing worse than wandering into
that fog would be sitting in the broken
down van watching Tweedle dumb and
Tweedle Dumber try to attend to the
failing engine his private joke almost
lifted his mood but not quite he popped
open the door and stepped out into the
cold damp air well figure it out I'm
going to go look around Dr bride shoved
his hands into his pockets and not
knowing what might wait on the other
side began his walk into silent hill
with each step he ruminated on the
events that had gotten him here where
did those guys at the foundation get off
disciplining him like an unruly child
sure he liked his pranks he enjoyed a
good joke and maybe sometimes he took it
just a little bit too far but he'd like
to see them confront the existential
dread of immortality without needing a
humorous Outlet every now and then
they'd crack under the pressure without
a release of some kind so what gave them
the right to put him a brilliant if
unconventional mind in some kind of
glorified time out he scoffed out loud
to himself and the sound echoed in the
VAC in streets the sheer emptiness of it
all snapped him out of his self-pity and
for the first time he looked up to take
in his surroundings the stubborn fog
refused to dissipate no matter how far
he walked but at least he could make out
the shape of the buildings now of parked
cars on the side of the road no not
parked wrecked abandoned left to rust he
scanned the fog for human Silhouettes
listened for voices for any signs of
life but there was no one he approached
a building and found it dilapidated
rotted wood collapsing in on itself
windows cracked door boarded uptight the
buildings next to it looked very much
the same what the hell he was sent to
investigate recent disappearances but
this town looked as if its entire
population had vanished decades ago or
he thought with a small shudder all
decided to to leave in a hurry what
could have driven them out okay that's
it I'm done Dr brigh remarked turning a
swift 180° and preparing to go back the
way he came as he did he froze for there
had once been continuous unbroken Road
the street now ended in a jagged edge a
deep dark Chasm the only thing that
waited Beyond it was too broad to jump
across and he couldn't see another road
out of town hey guys he called out
hoping to draw the attention of one of
the men he had left with the van a
little help over here but there was no
response hello he shouted again louder
this time when no one answered he
repeated to himself again and again with
increasing desperation his voice growing
horse from the effort had they somehow
fixed the van and left him there had
they fallen into the chasm where the
road once was and been killed on impact
there was no rational explanation for
what was at play here but as the
consciousness of a man living inside of
an ancient amulet reminded himself he
very rarely encountered rational things
in his life there had to be a way out he
just had to find it if he could go back
well he would just have to keep moving
forward on through the winding Labyrinth
of the street through the Maze of
crumbling buildings looking for any
signs of life he followed a natural Bend
in the road and suddenly found himself
wedged between two buildings down a
narrow claustrophobic alley it seemed
that this place didn't feel much like
playing by the ordinary rules of time
and space and while Dr brgh could
usually appreciate a rule breaker being
a little rebellious himself that
uncertainty was putting him on edge his
breaths came in Shallow gasps his chest
tight with apprehension as he turned in
a circle looking for the best way out he
heard a sound behind him the first noise
he had heard other than his own
breathing in quite some time it was the
soft plotting sound of uneven footsteps
like someone small walking with limp he
Whirled around to face the noise and saw
what he might have mistaken for a child
until he got a proper look at it the
thing that was steadily approaching him
was small and humanoid in shape but that
was where the similarities to a human
being ended its skin was a pale modeled
gray the shade of a body fished out of a
river after weeks of bloating and Decay
its mouth was a twisted gaping hole more
like a wound than a mouth and in place
of its eyes were a pair of slits in the
pale flesh it stumbled as it walked like
it was still learning how but the
childish ineptitude did nothing to
distract from the creature's Menace as
it Advanced towards Dr to right he saw
the glint of something metal in the
creature's gnarled fist it held a rusty
knife as it got closer it slashed
haphazardly in his Direction and its
mouth opened wider to let out a chilling
high-pitched giggle this thing was
preparing to carve him up and enjoy
every second of the job as he took in
the sight of the horrible gray child in
front of him Dr brgh had been frozen to
the spot unable to force his legs to
carry him away but the sight of the
knife the Grim realization of just
exactly what this thing had in store for
him shocked him back to life he grabbed
a wooden beam leading up against the
nearest wall and threw it at the little
monster knocking it onto its back it was
immobilized just long enough for Dr brgh
to get his bearings turn and run toward
the wider Street as he did he could hear
the gleeful laughter as the creature
climbed back to its feet and it only
pushed him to run faster when he could
no longer hear the Little Footsteps or
the Warped Giggles of the great child Dr
brigh stopped to catch his breath so it
seemed like there was still life in
Silent Hill after all there just wasn't
human life there was silence for a
moment nothing but Dr Bright's heart
pounding in his head as he bent over his
knees and silently cursed himself for
not exercising this body more often then
the shrill Cry of an aid siren ripped
through the foggy air and for a moment
his heart stopped what the hell did did
that sound mean he stood up inspecting
his surroundings for signs of danger for
what a tornado a bomb he wasn't sure but
nothing could have prepared him for what
he saw next the entire landscape had
shifted around him in an instant he was
unsure of how exactly to describe it
except to say that this world had gotten
darker more dangerous where the streets
had been lit by dim gray sunlight
filtered through the haze there was now
Darkness save for an occas Street Lamp
with a flickering red bulb he couldn't
be sure if it was a trick of the light
but he could swear there was blood
staining the street smeared across the
brick walls of buildings on either side
the town had been ominous before but now
it was like something out of a nightmare
and all the while the siren continued to
blare warning of a danger he could not
see he needed to find shelter that was
it from what he didn't know but whatever
was coming could not be good good Dr
brigh ran to the nearest door twisting
the knob trying to yank it open but it
wouldn't budge the hinges were rusted
shut and there was no time to try and
force them open he tried another door
and another and another it was as if the
house is new to try and keep him out to
keep him exposed and vulnerable on the
outside finally he reached a two-story
house with peeling white paint and a
mahogany door one that looked so
familiar but that he couldn't quite
place when he turned the knob the door
creaked open with ease and he quickly
raced inside slamming the door shut
behind him and longed it as Dr Wright
slumped against the door overtaken with
exhaustion an intrusive thought made his
stomach drop was he alone in this house
had he really found shelter or had he
just shut himself inside with something
even worse than what waited out there in
the silence he could swear he heard the
quiet thumping of a pulse but he
couldn't tell if it was his own or The
house's beating heart heart he couldn't
just stay here dreaming up all the
horrors that might be waiting he needed
to gather data investigate his
surroundings and come up with potential
Solutions he needed to be a scientist on
unsteady legs Dr brgh began to walk the
halls of the house taking in his
surroundings properly for the first time
it was Dusty and dark a place left
vacant for quite some time but there
were signs of a life once lived within
the House's walls a rocking horse in the
corner a Shelf full full of well-worn
books the titles scratched and itch in
his brain memories he hadn't touched in
decades strange that so many of the
books in this house would remind him of
the pages he once flipped through
staying inside to read while his brother
played in the yard outside his brother
Dr brigh swallowed the lump in his
throat at the thought of TJ no use going
down that path not right now he
continued his walk through the house
taking in the cobwebs the couch covered
with plastic the coffee table and the TV
set along the hall leading to the
bathroom there were rows of family
pictures hanging in neat little frames
he stopped to take a look wondering what
sort of family had once lived here as
his eyes fell on the first photograph
his blood turned to ice in his veins a
boy looked out from within the frame a
familiar boy with a mop of red hair a
freckled nose and kind smiling eyes no
Dr brgh whispered to himself but there
was no no denying it it was TJ his
brother somehow looking at him from
inside a photograph in an abandoned
house in Silent Hill next there was a
photo of TJ and an older man Dr Bright's
stomach turned their father every
photograph was of his family the family
he would never know again not the way
they were and there in one photo in the
middle TJ and his father were joined by
another figure one with the face
scratched out of the picture he knew
though he couldn't see for certain that
it was him removed from the family photo
by force but the bond between them all
forever broken TJ's eyes in the picture
seemed to be filled with tears
heartbroken his father glowed out of the
frame at him pure hatred in his gaze he
couldn't look anymore and turned away on
the opposite wall another photograph of
TJ was waiting Dr brigh fell bile rising
in his throat he recognized the photo he
saw it sometimes when he closed his eyes
at night was a picture taken with SCP
978 the desire camera the anomalous
camera that reveals its subject's
innermost Desires in the photo TJ's
hands were pressed to the lens like an
animal clawing at the boundaries of its
cage his eyes were filled with tears
spilling over and streaming down his
cheeks and his mouth was wide open in an
endless scream of fear and Agony this Dr
brigh knew was the wordless scream
inside his brother's mind at all times
after so much testing with the
foundation had destroyed him I tried to
help you he whispered to the picture I
did what I could do I did what I could
to take the pain away he trailed off the
words dying in his throat as the sound
of a heavy rattling breath came from the
room at the end of the hall it was a
thick wheezing sound like a death rattle
a dozen times over he didn't want to see
what was making the noise but as if in a
trance he found his feet carrying him
towards it he crossed the thr of what
should have been in the kitchen but
instead found himself in a dimly lit
Hospital the air smelled of faldy and
dried vomit the steady beep of a heart
monitor joining the course of heavy
agonizing breathing at the end of The
Long Hall there was one single room the
door standing slightly ajar with slow
agonizing steps Dr brght approached the
room the breathing grew louder and
louder the beep of the heart monitor
almost deafening in his ears he could
barely separate the the strange
breathing from his own finding his
breaths coming in time with the painful
rattling sound he pushed the door open
and saw figure lying in a hospital bed
it was once human but it could only be
described now as a conglomerate of
disease and pain on top of the figure's
head thinning in patches but still
recognizable was a lock of red hair no
TJ no Dr Brit's voice broke off in a sob
at the sight the thing that was once his
brother turned seeking the sound of his
voice though he could not see isn't this
what you wanted a low voice rumbled
behind him Dr BR Whirled around to see a
dark shadow red eyes glowing in the low
light it moved like a whsp of black
smoke but he knew that voice well enough
to tell him just who it was his father
you let them do this to him I I didn't I
didn't mean for this to happen Dr brgh
stammered you didn't care the demon
father roared and the light bulb above
their heads flared and burst sending
shards of glass scattering everywhere
all he ever did was help people to heal
pain and all you ever did was cause it
Dr bride found the strength to move
running through the doorway sending the
shape of his father in every direction
as the smell of sulfur and blood filled
his nose I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry
he wept as he ran hearing his father's
agonized cries his brother's labored
breathing as he for back down the
hospital Hall as he did hands began to
reach through the walls the floor the
ceiling they were Rotting Flesh gone
green and stiff arms followed the hands
then shoulders then faces he recognized
d-class uniforms lab codes face after
familiar face everyone who had ever worn
The Amulet he realized with a sudden
wave of nausea everyone whose body he
had taken who he had killed so that he
could live this is what what you do he
could hear his father's voice just
behind him the curls of black smoke
nipping at his heels what kind of
creature kills to live something that
deserves to die but you can't can you
you're a parasite sucking all the good
in the life from this world until it's
an empty husk just like you the living
graveyard of victims reach for Dr brght
tearing at his clothes as he passed them
there were so many he never realized how
many until he saw them all lined up like
this I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm so sorry he
said to every face he passed but there
was no forgiveness in their dead eyes
his father's voice fell silent but there
was no reprieve instead there was the
sound of heavy footsteps pursuing him
the gring shriek of a large bladed
weapon dragging along the ground Dr BR
glanced over his shoulder and saw a
massive hulking figure like a man but
with a jagged metal pyramid covering his
head he was cl FL in Blood Stained
clothing and approaching Dr Bry with the
Casual Menace of something that had
killed endless times before and was
ready to do it again it didn't care to
chase him it knew it would eventually
catch up as he looked at the figure it
began to warp to change it morphed into
something else something he recognized a
man with black hair and gray eyes that
revealed nothing but cold malice a body
covered in tattoos of the Arcane and the
occult of merciless grinning faces
belonging to ancient monsters and in his
hand a long bladed weapon a curved sword
perfectly engineered for battle it was
impossible he should be contained but
there he was SCP
076-2 looking at Dr brgh the same way he
had on the day he had first worn The
Amulet the day he became an Abomination
the sound of his brother's breathing
grew louder his father's voice bellowing
in his mind and he felt the grasp of the
Fallen Foundation employees at his back
it was all too much too many reminders
of every failure every hurt Dr brigh
collapsed to his knees and bared his
neck to Abel in submission you're right
I I should be punished I've done nothing
but hurt and kill and destroy everything
I touch just punish me please I'm
pegging you then something Dr brigh
never could have expected the figure
that looked like AEL but couldn't be
began to laugh a Hollow
sound no it said in a voice that sounded
like a chorus of hundreds we will
release you nothing we can do here will
ever be worse than the eternity of
Torment that stretches before you good
luck to you Dr bright Jack brigh let out
a whale of Agony reaching out to Abel
with pleading hands as the entity turned
and slowly walked away leaving him there
alone with the hell that was his
thoughts then everything faded to Black
Dr brigh Dr brigh the sound of one of
his team members brought Dr Wright back
to Consciousness and he opened his eyes
he was lying on the side of the same
road he had walked along before right
next to the sign welcoming the group to
Silent Hill you're all still here he
asked weakly what do you mean the man
looked puzzled we parked the van you got
out you fell down and we've been trying
to wake you up how long was I out Dr
Bright's Vision swam as he tried to wrap
his mind around the information I don't
know about 10 minutes have you ever had
a nightmare that you're running down a
long dark hallway getting chased by
something you can't see the thing behind
you isn't fast but that doesn't matter
you can't run forever and the thing
knows it it is a patient Predator it
toys with its food at first you move
with speed and Rhythm the metallic
scraping noise behind you grows quieter
you run and stumble through the dark
your muscles start to ache and your
lungs burn your pace slows it's still
coming you can hear the scraping getting
louder you start to Panic it's
completely dark you don't know where
you're running or even what you're
running from all you know as you bump
against the walls and the sharp Corners
that Rush towards you is that you can't
run forever you trip fall and pain
explodes through your legs as your knee
shatters on the concrete ground that
scraping is getting louder you can
barely breathe you can't run anymore
with your injury there's no way to stop
what's coming there is no escape the
scraping is right behind you you scream
and then you wake up your heart is
pounding like thunder in your chest and
your sheets are soaked with sweat but
you're safe you're out of those awful
dark hallways but what if this wasn't
just a nightmare what if this scenario
was real and there was no escape from
the horror chasing you in the darkness
that's what it's like to have a close
encounter with SCP
1918 a sadistic sentient object that
loves playing Twisted games with its
prey but this monster never plays fair
and even worse it's always just a simple
doorway it may even be hiding behind a
door near you right now waiting to start
a game with its new playmate but soon
you'll understand why some doors should
never ever be opened and why some games
are better left unplayed SCP 1918 is an
anomaly with two parts SCP 1918 itself
and SCP 1918 d2e monsters underground
layer the duo are a match made in hell
as the chambers and hallways of
1918-20 violent Hobbies nobody knows how
long this anomaly has been operating but
it's probably behind countless
disappearances after all 1918 has a
habit of breaking its toys the nightmare
began in a small town in Maine with a
population of only 226 people but that
population was about to get lower people
in the town began to report strange
noises at night a droning metalon
concrete scraping noise like someone
dragging a lead pipe along the ground at
first people just ignored the sound it
was all in their heads or maybe just a
faulty oven or a washing machine on the
fritz anything that would allow them to
forget about the noise and get on with
their daily lives but the noises were
coming from below they could be heard
out on the streets most audibly near
manholes and Sewer grates people started
feeling unsafe in their homes the noises
were spooking animals and children
people were losing sleep that scraping
they all tried to ignore was beginning
to get to the mall letters emails and
angry phone calls to the town Council
were piling up something had to be done
before the whole town went crazy with
fear the mayor authorized four utility
workers to investigate the source of the
noise at a local sewage treatment
facility considering the scraping was
loudest near the sewer grates everyone
just assumed that whatever was causing
all this must be connected to the sewers
four utility workers were sent to
investigate the facility only to find
that the Machinery on site was working
just fine the source of the problems
must have been coming directly from the
underground sewer lines themselves the
four workers equipped with headlamps
descended into a long surface tunnel
that fed into the sewer system as they
passed deeper into the tunnel the
darkness around them became thicker it
was a tangible presence that drowned out
the light of their headlamps similar to
the anomalous phenomenon exhibited by
SCP 087 when the utility workers tried
to turn back they discovered another
impossibility it seemed that the tunnel
behind them had become a solid concrete
wall they were trapped but where it was
too dark to tell confused and terrified
the four men stuck together attempting
to find a way out it was too dark to see
their hand in front of their face so all
they could do was navigate Slowly by
feeling the walls around them these
walls felt old crusty there was a kind
of faint metallic stench hanging in the
air too like old blood something
horrible had happened here and something
horrible was about to happen again all
they could do was keep moving and try to
stay calm eventually after hours of
pawing at the walls in the dark they
found an open doorway one by one they
filed inside only to feel blinded when
bright white ceiling lights suddenly
switched on the room was all white and
filled with pipes large and small
running from wall to wall just then one
of the utility workers let out an
earsplitting scream and pointed towards
the doorway his his colleagues turned
and gasped in shock there was something
outside the door and it was staring at
them the object filled up almost the
entire doorway it seemed like a demonic
hobby horse made from a black and white
candy striped metal pole with a crude
plastic head on top the head looked like
a clowns with a wide toothy grin but no
visible eyes it was SCP
1918 the utility workers were frozen as
the object leaned for lowered slightly
and slithered into the room the bottom
of the metal pipe scraping against the
ground it was the exact same scraping
noise that had been haunting the
concerned towns folk up above this was
the thing behind it all and as the
object moved its metal po started to
scrape words into the ground Tick Tac
Toe none of the four utility workers
were ever seen again it didn't take long
for the SCP Foundation to descend upon
this quiet main town and pick pick up
the pieces all relevant officials were
provided them n scks and cover stories
were created for the disappearances of
the four utility workers the foundation
also commandeered the sewage treatment
facility that held the entrance to SCP
1918-20 was given a uclid classification
due to the fixed nature of its hunting
grounds and then the real research began
the foundation soon made some disturb
ing discoveries entrances into the SCP
1918-20 can be entered from almost any
location if you're unlucky enough there
are currently nine known entrances
including five sewage grates three
utility shafts located in the sewage
facility and one toilet and these are
just the ones that the foundation knows
about there are a huge number of ways to
enter scp1 19182 2 but to this day
nothing has ever been able to leave SCP
19182 is contained 20 M below the
streets of this unassuming main Town
Personnel aside from Foundation approved
d-class guinea pigs are refused entrance
researchers have mapped out the layout
of
198-217 movements there are 18 identical
room pairs in scp1
19182 or nine compound rooms rooms are
differentiated between a one room and a
two room by crude carvings on the floors
outside of the individual rooms scp1 191
18-2 is symmetrical with half a meter
wide path circling each compound room
the only deviation to this construction
are the location of entrances on the
sides of each individual room which vary
randomly while the location is active
what exactly does SCP 1918 do in this
private little maze it plays games of
course it's two fa favorites as
indicated by the words it scrapes into
the ground are tick tac toe and memory
in tick taaco 1918 moves to each one
room leaving behind X markings on the
floors if the room is not already marked
with an o in a manner similar to a game
of Tic-Tac toe how a victim is meant to
accomplish making a Mark or
understanding this process is unknown as
no AIDS are given blood is commonly used
by victims to make their markings hence
the rusty smell in many of the rooms in
memory the trapped victim is rendered
unconscious by blunt force presumably
from SCP 1918 the subject regains
Consciousness in a random section of the
facility success is marked by finding a
one room identical to the central room
this event seems to possess a time limit
as the subject is pursued by SCP 1918
through the halls of the facility the
subject wins by marking the correct room
with an O what happened happens if you
win or lose these games it's important
to note that scp1 1918 is very
competitive and doesn't play fair if you
win the object will merely accuse you of
cheating and start a new game this will
happen again and again until eventually
you lose and what do you do well take
the horrifying encounter d-class
Personnel member D 2934 had with SCP
1918 wearing video and audio equipment
d2930 before was led into SCP
1918-20 challenged him to a game of
Tic-tac-toe and Against All Odds D 2934
won the game but 1918 didn't take kindly
to that it accused D 2934 of cheating
carving its accusations into the ground
before challenging him to a deadly game
of memory after hours of chasing D 2934
eventually l lost his mind and was
backed into a corner by 1918 as the
object made its way towards him he
panicked ripped a pipe from the wall and
began smashing 1918s head as the plastic
cracked under the force of the blows
Foundation scientists could see real
brains inside D 2934 screamed and the
video feed cut off when the video turned
back on sometime later 1918 stared into
the camera with a different head mounted
at top its metal pole one that just a
few hours earlier had belonged to the
unfortunate
d2930 if there's one lesson to be
learned from this terrifying anomaly
it's that there truly Is No Escape from
SCP
1918 you're sitting in the middle of a
cheering crowd the arena around you is
electric fans hollering from their seats
as they watch the basketball game every
Point scored every shot missed and every
skillful pass of the ball sends waves of
excit excitement over everyone in the
audience Applause shouts and chant fill
the air it distracts you for a moment
you find yourself swept up in the energy
of the game but slowly surely a nagging
feeling creeps up on you as your eyes
follow the ball that feeling turns to a
sickening realization as one of the
players jumps and dunks the basketball
scoring another two points you notice
the look on his face the same look on
the faces of all the other players on
the Court a solemn hopeless expression
it's the same look of Silent despair
worn by all the spectators around you
then you remember you've watched this
exact game of basketball before many
many times before and that is when you
feel the same hopeless expression appear
on your own face realizing just how long
you have been here watching this game
over and over reminded that you will
will never ever leave this Arena welcome
to SCP
1733 to the untrained eye SCP 1733 seems
to be a completely harmless item stored
in a digital video recorder it is kept
securely in the dusty depths of the SCP
foundation's video archives if any
researcher is given permission to study
SCP 1733 they will find it to be an
ordinary VHS tape but what about the
contents of said tape does it contain a
bizarre disconnected series of black and
white video clips that when viewed only
give the Watchers 7 days before the
spirit of a drowned girl comes crawling
out of their TV screen to kill them well
not exactly but we're sure that if such
a tape exists the foundation probably
has it under lock and key too the
footage on SCP 1733 is as seemingly
benol as the ordinary VHS tape itself
when played the viewer will witness a TV
broadcast of a basketball game
specifically the 2010 2011 NBA season
opener broadcast on television and
captured on tape by an unknown civilian
the game took place on the 26th of
October 2010 in the TD Garden arena in
Boston Massachusetts a game where the
hometown Boston Celtics took on the
Miami Heat by now perhaps you are
wondering what is so special about this
particular game and why the SCP
Foundation would be so interested in
keeping a VHS recording of it so secure
is one of the5 Council secretly a
Celtics fan well that's impossible to
say for sure what we do know for certain
is that SCP 1733 is far more than just a
harmless recording of a basketball game
the SCP Foundation First caught wind of
SCP 1733 is existence the day after the
game on October 27th a Boston native
that had watched and recorded the game
made comments on social media about a
technical foul that the game's referee
had failed to pick up on according to
this individual during the third quarter
an instance of unsportsmanlike conduct
took place between Ray Allen and Chris
Bosch the person making these claims was
quickly ridiculed by commenters on the
same thread but then this person
uploaded a clip of this foul from the
footage they had recorded the other
commenters were dumbfounded during the
original broadcast that foul had never
happened but the recording showed it
clearer as day the footage was quickly
expunged and all traces of the clip
removed from the Internet by Personnel
acting on behalf of the SCP Foundation
any that had viewed the video on
Facebook or been a part of the comments
debating this previously nonexistent
foul were Tracked Down via their IP
addresses all of them including the
owner of the tape were given amnestics
to wipe their memories of the supposed
infraction and SCP 1733 was returned to
the foundation for further analysis
researchers at the foundation were
determined to understand the anomalous
nature of SCP 173 3 and why the footage
contained on this particular VHS tape
was so different from the basketball
games original broadcast at first the
differences in the game seemed to be
only slight changes from the one that
actually aired on TV a different fou
here a small Point difference there
while the recording of the game
contained on SCP 1733 was slightly
different from the real life game
perhaps even more interesting was that
these differences changed with repeat
viewings researchers wouldn't observe
the same differences every time they
watched SCP
1733 but would instead spot something
different that had been changed each
time they restarted the tape and as they
continued to watch and rewatch SCP 1733
is footage the true horror of the
video's anomalous properties became more
and more apparent as the footage
recorded on SCP 1733 began to diverge
more and more from the original
broadcast researchers shifted their
attention away from the basketball game
itself and on to the people watching it
just like the specifics of the game
itself the fans in the arena seemed to
also change with every rewatch of the
tape and even stranger the people in the
crowd seemed to not only be aware of
their existence within the footage but
also retain memories of every previous
replayed Vision each time the
researchers had watched SCP 1733 the
audience trapped within had gained more
and more cognizance every man woman and
child in the audience of that basketball
game began remembering that they had
seen multiple variations of the same
game over and over again this first
became apparent to Foundation
researchers when the game's commentators
two presenters named Mike and Tommy
began to comment on a strange sense of
deja vu they were experiencing as they
watched the Boston Celtics and Miami
Heat play both seemed to share Notions
that the game they were witnessing was
strangely familiar and in later replays
of the tape these two commentator
personalities were able to recall the
events of the game with perfect Vivid
accuracy well they never addressed the
viewer directly this cumulative effect
seems to have extended to every person
that was present within the arena at the
time that the original broadcast was
recorded everyone from the commentators
to the coaches the players to the
patrons all remember the diverging
versions of the basketball game but seem
to have no awareness that they are
trapped inside recording on a VHS tape
it should be noted that it is still
unclear whether the entities are real
people or digital copies that solely
reside on the tape every individual
shown to be inside Titi Garden on the
26th of October 2010 seems to be
identical to their counterparts in the
real world each of the basketball
players on both the Boston Celtics and
Miami Heat teams have the exact same
level of talent as they do in reality
and their individual mannerisms are
perfectly recreated in the SCP 1733
footage and the same is true of the fans
and the audience each one appearing to
be in every conceivable way a living
human being but the most unnerving
aspect of SCP 1733 was found when the
foundation agents were tasked with
tracking down members of the audience
who were seen on the tape and they found
nothing unlike the players in coaches
who can quite easily be found in our
world with many of them still playing or
involved with professional basketball
Personnel were unable to find a single
trace of any of the people from the
audience not one clue as to their
current whereabouts or status it is
unclear how but it appears that everyone
shown on SCP
1733 especially those watching the game
unfold from the stands is a person
trapped in digital form stuck watching
variations of the same match on Loop
researchers at the SCP Foundation who
were studying SCP 173 33 initially
theorized that the tape had been
designed to display an infinite variety
of different game outcomes given that
the tactics utilized by the players were
different with each playback of SCP
1733 this seemed to be the case that the
tape was showing a whatif scenario each
time the tape was rewound and played
from the start but the scenario wasn't
resetting each time it was clear that
they were learning by the 34th replay of
the footage the Boston Celtics and Miami
Heat were so in tune with the opposing
team's Playbook that both sides players
were able to perfectly and precisely
counter their opponent's moves and kept
the score at 0 for much of the game at
this stage in the foundation's research
the players on the SCP 1733 tape had not
yet become fully aware that they had
played the same game already in earlier
playbacks but it is possible that weak
memories of the earlier versions of the
same match manifested as instinctive
ways players could counter the moves of
their rival team however by the time
Foundation researchers had replayed the
SCP 1733 footage 45 times the players
their coaches and fans watching the game
had become aware of what was happening
to them it was at this point that the
digital recording from TD Garden changed
dramatically realizing that they'd been
playing the same game of basketball over
and over the players refused to
participate any longer everyone in the
audience began to attempt to escape from
the tape they'd been unknowingly
imprisoned but not a single one of the
Stadium's doors would budge and neither
the fans nor the players seemed to be
able to leave through any other exit out
of TD Garden over the following
playbacks of the SCP 1733 videotape
attempts at Escape grew increasingly
daring in one playback a full-scale riot
broke out in another makeshift
explosives were built and used by those
trapped to try and blast their way to
Freedom as their cognition grew and they
began to remember friends and family
from outside the videotape the crowd
trapped in SCP 1733 grew even more
desperate players and their coaches
retired to locker rooms withdrawing from
the crowd for a Time the rest of the
people in the footage began to form
factions amongst themselves one of the
more prominent calling themselves the
faithkeepers these individuals voiced
their belief that they had been confined
to TD Garden as some form of spiritual
punishment as a result of the
consumerism that is rif in opposed
industrial society the faithkeepers
began burning offerings in the center of
the basketball court phones wallets car
keys anything that reminded them of the
modern world over the subsequent
playbacks of SCP 1733 the faithkeepers
grew in their numbers indoctrinating
more of the crowd into their movement
those still trying to escape from the
stadium were causing more damage to
themselves in their enclosure with three
men caught in the blast of another crude
bomb placed on an exit door
unfortunately for them the door barely
showed a scratch in the aftermath of the
detonation as Foundation researchers
continued replaying the tape those
trapped with an SCP 1733 descended into
depraved AXS and incidences of violence
became rampant some even attempted to
take their own lives in Acts of
desperation jumping from balconies in
the hopes of ending the loop those that
had joined the growing ranks of the
faithkeepers did not engage in such
Behavior instead creating makeshift
curtains to separate themselves from the
breakdown that was taking place among
the others trapped within the SCP 1733
tape at some point beyond the 112th
playback of the videotape the
faithkeepers marched off scream and
brought the basketball teams back out
onto the main Court they then began a
ritualistic sacrifice disbaling the
professional athletes for their fellow
prisoners to see this had no noticeable
effect with the recording of the the
game resetting as it had done in earlier
rewatches in a later playback the
faithkeepers then began to call for all
the children in the stadium to be
sacrificed in the same way testing on
SCP 1733 was finally suspended
indefinitely after this point and as far
as we know the crowd remains trapped
inside the anomalous recording of this
particular Celtic's Heat basketball game
Foundation researchers have been unable
to produce the same anomalous effects as
those of SCP
1733 even when using the DVR that
originally produced the recording the
digital video recorder itself does not
seem to imprint the same properties onto
other VHS tapes making SCP 1733 an
isolated anomaly however the next time
you find yourself at a basketball game
it might be worth asking yourself have I
seen this game before now check out SCP
1861 the crew of the HMS winter shimer
and SCP 133 7 The Hitchhiker for more
Chilling Tales from the SCP Foundation